[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sorry y'all we think we gotta fix let me
know if you can hear us again Mic Check
Mic Check
there we go hello we there Maxie says
okay now that's what's up one more
person let me show you okay hey
everybody please talk to me oh yeah
everyone I know that we go over all
straight into it
Oh before you roll into it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my god all right we save I'm saving the
day
coach the coast you already know all
good now that Caesar does it does it
those was uh more the patreon on YouTube
thing doesn't that look better
oh now he really wanted glow I was just
being realistic
yes what do you mean why he didn't like
I didn't like how it went over the the
emos aid Oh laughs welcome oh wow
cat daddy actually what's up we have a
few below please please go back to those
what yes do the troll guy cat daddy to
da super check it's stuck in my head oh
good part to anyone if we make why we
had you guys just do that I'll find them
okay no doubt and we all laugh welcome
to the islands podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 162 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guest and
we've got the PlayStation 5 reveal
spider-man Miles Morales and switch
hacking to discuss so we go get right
into it but before we get into it we had
a fun time six
it's that King but King can't read it
cuz it's not on the screen anymore not
King you need to do a kos on these you
are collecting and give the background
story Oh
so alright so during room did it do that
trust me that is all me we got yeah we
go get it we got it straightened out
we've got if there was just so much
going on this way put the [ __ ]
every other it was every day that we had
some livestream will use doing we didn't
want to make any huge changes and mess
up everything I know crea Graf got mad
at me but I just had to pull it back
only because we have girls ready shot
too and watching music for dollar super
chat salute you already know don't crush
the smart again so let's get so you know
what it's do so Lord whose enthusiasm
for the PlayStation brand is only
matched by his passion for the latest
technology on every gaming platform
introducing the creating host of the
blades 4k YouTube channel and a
panelists for both the solid cast in our
GT podcast the PlayStation 5 and Vita
punchline King and the only Lord with
the most iconic catchphrase in the game
its Saudi baby laugh from wisdom of
making his debut into the realm of the
lords mommy Lord blaze 4k how we doing
sir oh I'd give you that P okay that
baeksan blaze we don't even get those
intros we leave in the park know what up
babe let's go brother yo hi you beador
alright oh yeah ready for that be your
light you get ready for these content
don't get ready for last of us o 9606
box okay you got a double that with the
with the well you might as well put the
down payment down for the next 100 K 40
could you check a board in it man oh
stop stop
hustling motivation said not six blaze
lit up that's what I'm feeling the
diner's Bobby and I saw I saw hustle
he's a new permanent member of scum cast
I actually think that was a good thing
though I fall for a Christopher Hart in
the building so yeah pretty much let's
just all destiny just chill and get
ready for this last of us what you been
doing with that I watched that I watched
that tragedy with PC gamers showing oh
yeah we go get whoo yeah it was it was
pretty bad was a bit spooky no other
than that I'm waiting for my plug to
bring me laughs if you can bring me
laughs so so I'll have it like four days
early you know but if not a method wait
like everybody knows if you're the game
today I could see the Flex that's what's
up you already know goes to the perfect
Shogun two hours of a chat I think we
had $10 super Philly ago just want to
confirm the future of gaming cording to
the PS 5 Ervil is the same thing that
Xbox has been telling you it would be
since Phil took over had checked same
energy have fun has tech gamers unite
what else we got - we get perfect Shogun
with the 2014 we got a $2.00 super champ
from perfect show going
King David can we get a debate is it's
PS 5 baby the blade excessive book of
solely baby does mr. cat from from what
you call is that 28 torture the building
he already knows to Lou
so you already know we got the Four
Horsemen of gaming those rhythm Lords in
Rome here to round table my co-host the
core most saving the podcast my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror
Lord of reviews and the half of the
young both my man know what addict how
we doing sir doing pretty good now uh
alright so we do have an update so for
those either new that we put a tweet up
earlier this week yes talking about
we actually because of the generosity of
yes you know everyone subscribing to the
patreon we actually can have two new
emails now so
we're gonna choose one is Denise because
obviously yes say that that's that's
what that's what we like doing the
second one we wanted to give our members
and we wanted to give our patreon the
opportunity to pick it we gave the
option between book IX on guarding them
onto something in the goat in our book
x100 on patreon it was eight votes than
the nearest one was two and on the place
on the PlayStation on the members for
the podcast it looked like it was 62%
said and they'll be preparing the Royal
needs
salutations Lords and shout out to the
frauds trying to flip and bounce my
plague sir I've actually I've been
playing play Kingdom Hearts cuz the cave
game passed forever but it came not yes
I was thinking that you know I was
actually looking was like did this to
the dis announced become on April the
first like are they ever gonna do this
like what they did I'm still waiting for
that Final Fantasy 10 to hit up yeah you
know in
my chosen to build it's fierce enemy
gamers and let's go attic you let that
keep the hearts that game that game has
4,000 gamerscore
oh yes yep I was just like you know I'm
never gonna get all these I'll be lucky
to get a thousand eight now gonna cross
all the games cause well the game's four
thousand across like there's but there's
like six games alright yeah that's still
a lot did they look reasonably they look
like ridiculously yes I didn't even look
at them there was there were so many I
was intimidated Kingdom Hearts I've been
playing destiny a lot here lately and I
play I've been playing divinity original
sense - a lot - and of course we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
player coolest for the single player
selfish experience and also disaster
Damas mr. offline profile Illuminati and
lower patron of the I baked my man Louis
I of how we doing sir doing good man
what's going on hello man first I want
to apologize for having to dip out last
week without a moment's notice Lords
well and and you guys and of course of
me what do you read out with with the
best wishes thankfully everything is
good my dad took a little bit of a
thrill he's on the men right now so but
thank you I appreciate any chance to
gain this week anything even playing so
last week we don't really have talked
about what I was doing but I I didn't
play any AC Odyssey this week but as we
got was able to finally get into the
fate of Atlantis DLC mmm I'm in chapter
1 which after one takes you to Elysium
it's it's beautiful like it it has like
an ethereal feel the way Elysium should
feel yeah yeah it's real nice is really
nice so I'm excited to get it to that at
some point but beat one I had to had to
get back into the Last of Us um I wanna
I want to go into part two having all
the small little details of part one yes
right again same where you at right now
you all
right I just got to the to the
University
okay okay I don't know okay okay yeah
yeah I just got to hungry I'm still
early anyway will you be all black of
his son brother yeah brother yeah you
already replayed at the kids food for
show me all the necessary was like
that's how I was like not a cord again
so I did that so I'm in the middle of
that hopefully I'll be finished with
that by the time Thursday rolls around
cuz much like blaze [ __ ] it the mr. Lee
hook up before Friday no song that was
some space for you speedy Smith with the
final switch at louis-style I'm glad the
family's good brother I sent positivity
to you and your salute thank you my
brother much appreciate it's a low as
low G royalty in a bill man man in the
child that's blasphemous from bathroom
hold on did he just dis old that's all
we got Rand outdoor a legend we are for
saw him on Twitter like open e 2 cap
horrible alchemy why why no but des des
we got to know this sir god I gotta give
you a reason oh so so it was so great oh
they betrayed you too
ok God God with the enemy that's right
they can have that because that game
looked horrible
[Music]
that's one thing but they can have
whatever that was it looks like these
games okay and when I like your reacted
like I've never played disorder it did
disorder
we're arguing about dishonored it wasn't
disorder did this say disorder three at
the beginning anyway let me speak
nothing like this on moving on of event
a great quick but desert his Jane has
been the epitome of epitome of
positivity to support of all platforms
they don't do this ish but this is the
this is way out of character from
another color you had to speak to the
garb and PlayStation Shop the bag up
being a god yeah because the game needed
to be funded nobody wanted that game
with it after seeing it I could see why
yes so Muni games for the lineup I don't
care about that game that's a pretty
much pretty much its off yes pretty much
out and of course we have the accredit
of this a.k.a the access game you're
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement
you're you stupid beloved lower kick how
we doing sir debuted year
[Music]
any sort of kos this is one of my
favorite thought statues and the reason
why I like it because his hand is
cutting the wind right before you
busting your hair with that hammer
just like today scouts know I'm coming
for the me captain weak ass boy FedEx
ships do you know what you can throw
that okay so you know all you guys so
two pitches you know one down in the man
cave so you know picked up another Xbox
because the show was so trash I was like
I might as well double down are you
saying that place that your show was so
bad but the only way you could get that
that foolishness out of you from
watching is you had to go and buy
another Expo so you know I'm gonna take
a royal flushing you had to flush it out
of you I was looking all at all my games
as I was doing it okay let me put this
for download let me do this for download
I had a moment I had a moment I was like
yo this year sometime I'm gonna do this
again
all my new xbox is all my rooms I'm
gonna do the same thing again and
everything that I see here is gonna
transform for smart delivery now see you
and then I had a moment I was like you
who did you put that commercial back in
the days and he sort of Indian and he
was looking out and then he wente on the
side of his eyes yes I was like yeah
well I feel just like now man feel
dominus Maximus soon with me Aurelius
he's out here
waving and we never had a family we've
never had this feeling like feeling of
safety yes what what you got is what you
gonna bring with you like that security
that's like that secured yeah I like I
like the fact that I don't have to go to
the store with all my D yell out of here
like I really actually love the fact
that I'm secure like I'm secure like in
a relationship you know you have a nice
relationship there's no lying there's no
cheating you like a transparent so what
I was playing today was being past with
their no man sky complete edition yes
first launch today that's cuz that's cuz
there's over there on PlayStation then
all y'all and y'all being networked a
ton of for praise kind of source in
networks but I really want to appreciate
you and tell you thank you we've been
down because place they should people
come over to play actual co-op games and
it just tosses the whole network that
all best what you don't know okay
actually our baby tested it for so we
I'm real appreciative for that I was
playing that I downloaded all the
kingdom Hawk games I'm a big into those
Assassin's Creed Odyssey just did some
stuff and I was like man this game is so
great looking then what happened was I
wasn't able to be upstairs with my ex
right right another instance I'm
downstairs with the s/m and I'm like you
crazy like you know like I'm one I'm
going downstairs and then if I have a
problem
you know I pick up my phone if I got a
game that I'm playing this I mean the
scene was alleged a chat we got it the
rule of Kali squadron and the building
set up in LA right now no no we were 14
yeah we'd lead to know what we would be
home would only be
we'd be back here we've met waiting
three minutes on the toilet we got you
wrapped yeah I'll be back yeah we got
super chest real quick song we gotta
catch up
oh we got Luke Lord with the two other
super chapped Miles Morales this fire is
it on PS five and ps4 we will dig into
that a little bit later two dollars
super Jeff from being her eight one two
seven its Omni AK one with ratchet and
Spidey you know ratchet Clank look good
I don't know about that we got a $10
super chop from Robert I don't even try
Olsen yo King I got that CDL in a
flatbed if they don't fit they can be
shipped might need to take you up on
that because I don't think people [ __ ]
knees okay that's what he's as he's
telling me that he knows what he do to
work so pick them up on the bow so let's
go get that box a diesel okay yeah
that's about it and destiny you know I'm
just
oh that game was crazy yo Reno shout did
a scrub nurse he's like shout out to the
Lord's love what you guys bring keep up
the great work
hit that like button subscribe so d Baby
[Applause]
Doe v Lord Cognito spread that really
sort of rubber to IOT not tell me what
you want to hear what you need to hear
it's just a simple bed that's these back
so my life is over it's over soft that's
it that's it like we got new stuff
coming we got
cross-play coming you got next Jade Oh
better is good so you see what just
happened out I old every destiny fan as
destiny kept back came back they said
you're weak
we'll beat you anymore we're gonna buy
you all kinds of new stuff and we just
walk on the right back in that is a
beautiful abusive relationship a
domestic relations also please if you
get a chance bad if you guys are trying
to get back into destiny please watch
the last words
this Friday what many boxes and we have
my boy amazing of building your super
positive brother one of the best
freestyle twitch spitters you ever see
you raid his life if you know his soul
it King cuz he will off the top spit
about you it'll blow say like just
straight balls you don't say what you
did
blew his mind away with this to do
that's gonna carry me to the can I just
do click the joint way he was doing some
freestyle OTT of energy energy oh yeah
it's so much energy that I was
intimidated by the new standard do I
have to do this what's going on good do
but shout out to Smitty Smith shout out
to the last word you already know it
no Vasiliy suggesting to had expansion
battered wife syndrome yo you stupid
anyway for me but Lord solved we have to
take care of the room and iron bank is
once again plentiful overflowing so
gotta give back to the community so as
you guys know we had announced a gleam
IO giveaway for the Last of Us part two
and ninety-six like blaze said that
night next go out there in the wild so
uh yeah we have a winner ladies and
gentlemen may be abuzz
once again uh thank you to Louis now
though and the banhammer they have
awfully the banhammer on fleek 4,000
fraudulent entries all the frauds try to
get de Maynes and they cousin a free
last of us sleepy off-road yeah let's
try to hustle
no but they appreciate for
like you really want this so I get that
so I cannot just I'll go for that
four-foot see weeding through that and
you know y'all what their last of us
which I gotta relax the banhammer for
the police stations actual number so the
winner of the gleam I all I am Lord
podcast the last of us part to give away
Lord
wacky graduations I will be in your DMS
later pause it make sure you get that
code so you can get that download on
like the game is actually available to
download already so you have that ready
for Friday so long so congratulations on
that last of us to yo shout the Lords of
gamer down there the admin of all admins
hot 13 in the book good to see you
brother
haven't seen a minute could do now
usually we end 1-1 giveaway we usually
have another one to take its place
let me preface this by saying that the
iron bank did not cannot agree with this
giveaway you like this one yeah but you
know that could be overruled so so so
coming up next which it will start in
about ten hours if you've been on
Twitter it's already up you can see it
our next clean giveaway is destiny to be
on light the stranger edition with a man
so so be be clear to what version didn't
the NTSC version of the game does the
game come with this I don't know how
that works right in the game you
shouldn't be coming with this it is the
NTSC version so uh region one yes so
just be sure you before you get platform
platform-specific that one right because
that's a statute as a physical
collector's edition gay
stop exclusive the one with the stranger
on it that's coming at you yo you gonna
be the king of the statue in y'all know
well this is a PVC plastic vinyl
collection so basic that King wanted his
kids on it but we know no I want the
game this guy the guy that is the
cheapest version or whatever it is look
attics world denies your citizens listen
right I can get that win that joint I
will get a statue a way for free I don't
care citizenship I'm looking at here it
doesn't specify what it is we might have
to amend that a little bit so you said
you tell me which what the should become
it should be the Xbox version because
normally we do alter our platform
giveaways but in this case because it's
tied to a physical statue you have to
pick one version so one of the other
yeah that's what will be the Xbox you
don't so you'll get that that that
stranger that no time to explain all
that goodness all the extras with it
well at least at least least you know
when you say Xbox version y'all know
that y'all be able to play it on a
series access that's good so that opens
up in about ten hours so we'll be ready
for that and we will be sure to um
retweet that and put that out on Twitter
to make sure we remind people to jump on
that
and then one last thing so I give a
shout out I'm not gonna use his name but
a listener of the show was gracious
enough to give us a code for a game in
which he participated in this
Kickstarter in oh he wanted to give it
pass it forward to the realm so thank
you to him the game was called
Evans remains and it's for Steam so it's
a cozy always best to race well yeah
that you see master race where is that
um so the game is called Evans remains
and what I'm gonna do is I'm a little
Q&A in the chat right so the first
person in the chat
to put down the first game that how
smart games made for the PlayStation
platform place then what is the first
game that housemarque made for the
PlayStation platform you already got to
get to it you already know get to it
laws woke up for that shot let's get a
super chest shout out to the Persia
night $10 of a check put it towards the
bug snacks fund oh yeah we have trucker
hat hollowed to us super chat Knights
who say ni more like the Knights who
take me king throwing shade on his
portfolio join up like I got the new
statue and I'm just like you don't
really do I just want you to know what
understand what they purchase it like
you don't want to go to the store and
ask for a rabbit and get a snake right
so let me just tell you what some people
would be okay with getting a snake
instead of a riser ghost king we play
Battletoads a year ago now yeah and soon
that game would be a launch title for X
[Music]
we don't you talking about kiddie games
I got asked the panel we have a couple
of people that got it correct
technically now there's some there's
some misspelling so how do I want to
handle this the actual answer is Super
Stardust HD mmm no we have like the
finest came in first we just Stardust
which is not not really it right so we
can't do that sorry all right fine I
don't know I feel like Stardust gave me
the game no but is the original Stardust
came out in 1990 something like this
it's called HD that's the actual game
and Super Stardust are two different
games Oh HD version if they can try to
give up the bread alright the original
one came out in 1996 97 superstars came
out in 2007 okay mm-hmm who would
supersize sh t so so the first one to
put it was decks with anybody put Super
Stardust H II give it to him because he
probably had his keys right to Dax with
the with the W on this decks just get at
me in dams and I give me I will give you
a new brother but they had the beautiful
it had to be the floor look I'm with you
fine I'll be fine I would have bought a
PlayStation data watching
we got a $5 super check for an outdoor
night team shout out the little cog
meter for the epic conversation the
other day and lord King bend the knee
four bucks Nets grounded part - hey oh
do we got we got a little yeah we gotta
look law so all get caught up we good
are we good are we good we good I'm
let's get to the missile look we got on
to what the Lord's are playing all that
good stuff but we gotta talk to blaze
right quick
his video game system history his
passion for the PlayStation brand and of
course went led him on his journey to
creating the blaze 4k YouTube channel so
Lord blaze what was somebody's video
game sisters you had and what got you
into gaming alright so I was uh I was
outside do playing manhunt you know as a
kid madam what you know that's what I'm
over that okay that's East Coast that's
the East Coast so I did don't play man I
remember my dad from the window and I
look up and it's holding me yesterday
I ran upstairs I hope that all my seven
inch television yeah I mean I plugged it
in and wow I was for 8010 dole until
then whoo and then also I was like boom
I see let's this light coming from the
sky with a little gray the closer gut
box logo is a PlayStation so when we
witness transition all the way from the
NES huh we just went straight to plays
them
yeah yeah you know I mean when we buy
I'll tell them you buy the best game on
the genesis I'll buy the best game on
Nintendo so we have enough money back
then your enemies a wheelchair we'd be
like you know you buy a good game I'll
buy a good game you know come over a
balloon but I'm just skipping the
greatness you know oh all right so your
actual game in history games you
actually enjoy best wrestling games ever
ever end up you over bands and all them
facts do you have like a team that y'all
used to get together and play it oh
thanks yeah right but we kind of
dismantle over the year did I mean like
it's the Sun I can't really get it but
you know it
might meet my cousin and then I remember
dude I bought an Xbox right remember I
was gonna play hey what are you doing
right now my god
I just thought I just traded in my
playstation 2 it's at the time I was
gonna switch over to Xbox I want to play
I want to play Halo and stuff losing
halo secure yeah you're hosting an hour
that's why he's trying to skipper's then
you want to tell us who's played
excellent going on oh no I want it
solved so you know my cousin comes over
and he puts down a PlayStation clue the
so called what so called right I'm like
what's this we hook it up with the with
a little attachment to the ps2 I'll
remember that
yeah love the game bro when I tell you
so calm I was addicted I skipped school
for I did everything for it like it was
oh yeah so so calm literally kept me on
PlayStation in the ps3 I bought a ps3
right away because I knew so [ __ ] always
coming though that would keep me on the
ps3 now that SOCOM is gone yeah you know
I love bro look I
you guys know I love PlayStation but
mm-hmm I love my xbox t I just the
question which which silicon wasn't was
the one that was the on line that we
used to play at night so calm so come on
into but to was the big one to with the
big one that was the one where you could
be the militia do it and they had that
long hallway yes oh man what their game
back so bad coming back coming back to
they didn't he I can't believe you
remember the third person mode you can
hide behind yeah
yes yo we okay so all the times that we
used to play was dead in the middle of
the night right that's when we had the
best connection and stuff like that
because you know was on dollar back then
right so you know nobody's up nobody's
touching the phone you know I skip my
mom's one day with that but um I'm gonna
I'm talking to [ __ ] we decide the bushes
right wishes and I'm like y'all found
the tunnels I said if they come down
this tunnel I could smoke them
we want to I love that game so much
and we probably played together back in
the days not normally yeah this is so
amazing right now blade you'll hold a
woodcut shot to Simon break 5 pounds so
much at Kings got everybody's knees
surely now it's time to start collecting
tears for years okay
South the slow-mo coming at blaze he
said did he just call the SNES mediocre
cuz I need to know how much respect for
blaze I need to snatch away I'm just
telling you you can look at I just look
at blurry Claire eons and then I had 3d
games okay any of started audios in
respect to I'm just saying they're near
trash now oh right to it because I gotta
ask you this you know obviously you know
the the PlayStation brand you are
synonymous with the PlayStation brand so
my question is like what was it was it
so called almost a single a moment that
she'll like okay this is my favorite
platform is my favorite brand I'm I'm
all in on sodium what was the moment I'm
telling you when I tell you I put hours
into SOCOM it was so fun and not even
care about sin to play games I was just
solely on playing oh I'm so clever then
somebody did a transition like look
we're gonna be making great exclusive
new IPs
next score over 70 nobody but I know you
want to pander to your base but you got
to let your base know that you've been
really gaming dan you know a lot of
people this generation just started on a
Playstation right so I could see them
capping the hall all day for that I
started with Atari so when I'm when I'm
playing like colecovision and in
television and all these stuff right
there this is the fundamentals my
building blocks into gaming see gaming
was I understand why my allegiance is to
Microsoft because they're American
company not saying that you know it has
to be like that but that that a home
team right right so for when I look out
and I see everybody crapping on the home
team I remember when it was only the
home team it was only Atari it was only
colecovision it was only a television
and these conglomerates like that and
they fell out
favor and then the the other team came
and took over Nintendo bossed them out
the way then Sony came in then Sega
there so I remember what it was and then
Atari tried to come back and I got
smashed down then you know 3do try to
get up there
so all this is your history right and
it's building blocks to you so like what
games you was playing on what and we're
you know we know that you play station
all day Sony baby yeah but I know I know
that's what I asked you about so common
we use that with it so I'm gonna get to
the meat and potatoes gone cream probe
that was the first on the Dreamcast
literally means chat to the Dreamcast
let's go
potato Dreamcast was incredible man I
remember seeing that little logo pop up
and you have the little of the little
booty call them to VM you that you put
inside the controller yes dreamcast
honestly stole me for a while man and a
max I remember it was just they kind of
fellow asunder having me discontinued or
whatever in the know and the P axing oh
the ps2 came like literally the ps2 was
overshadowing the Dreamcast but I didn't
care I Miguel notice the Dreamcast
opinion you know I mean and then another
PS who came to kind of knocked it out of
the wavelets in unfortunate you know I
mean yeah oh sure live but but the Xbox
man I don't want to advocating play Halo
LAN parties let's experience it again
Xbox was great I'm just saying the
controllers yeah yes yeah yes controller
yeah we got it from Japan we couldn't
really
this is a great control if y'all know
like you can play this on your ex I love
this control I know it's neat but
nostalgia both you know it was for me
blaze when you see how you got the the
black and the white cameras I was so
amazed was played halo and you press
that and the light came on in halo oh I
was like oh you know history comes out I
was excited like oh I can play ps2 games
on it and they got rid of that but the
360 came out first right mm-hmm
the 360 literally book fear there's a
look inside you looking certain a 360
job 360 droppin put fear final choice
you what what did if we was into gear
like yeah Gary's I feel everything I
remember buying it 360 men like wow this
thing feels next-gen the control I gotta
give it a go salute that's big from you
that's big from you it's the best
all-time till the dooms drunk for chemo
when it came to like multi plants
on the when it came to light yellow but
with the whole nation was on the 360
because the Playstations party chat free
thank you everybody real on that that's
real that's what you know yes points
you know absolutely that 360 men stole
nights out of my you know I was
literally saying a party to all day and
yeah although that's a classic Barry
mmm-hmm but then you kept seeing a
parenting like alright
hey look ODST Bungie leave it cool
another halo and other gears another
force I mean like you know and I love
them absolutely man I just kind of fell
I'm like you know what this is where
this is home from this you know right
was trash yeah I'm not gonna you didn't
like the um the sixth sense of joint I
I thought that Sixth Sense journey was
nice like when he's able to guide it and
heavenly blade like we do the sword
oh my gosh for the battery but there
wasn't they first whiff that that hole
right there pioneered that and then once
they figured out like okay well you know
first couple of games used it because it
was a dragon game which I still love to
this day from it and I still got that
controller and I still got the old G fat
back one you know with the old play play
stuff I got that arm but when they went
away from it it kind of disappointed me
because I wanted to see them use like
other things like yeah could you imagine
God of War and you know doing that
accident I don't know I was and then we
came out and just took that message to a
whole different level so you know I'm
into that just because it's one thing I
did want to ask you actually made a
super gyro cook Army veteran salute
father some check yo what up loads if
you guys have a chance could you please
let me know what TVs you game or 4k 124
the upcoming series X right now talk to
possess ena COC CX
yeah tell me why not the CX below you
sir
you know you can get the CX if you're
strictly understand concepts it's fine
it might be an X it's fine but what they
did is HDMI 2.1 the bandwidth they
brought it down oh you'll see 48 my
shirts up this exits lower than that
going in is but it's just a point like
if this is your flagship TV why would
you downgrade in a sense even though but
you know how that you can one thing is
this I as soon as they told me they
could run it at 120 Hertz 4k wait mom my
thing is a chroma subsampling
once you tell me 444 I'm in like
everything else okay so once they did
that I was like alright I have to go
with the CX
that I know exactly what you're talking
about foothold on Auto hip-hop in the
building though hold on hip-hop slow
progress done he says Sony X 900 emotion
is crazy
yeah it is
shoutout to look inside work with me in
real quick I got showing a little you
already know dude is mad humble back you
know yeah it's my god joined in on him
and he's a girl yet we live that boss in
here and I played destiny with him every
time every time he gave me change each
other's numbers bags because there's
like before I would have been YouTube
Utah's for summer salute the hub and you
showed me I wanted eyes come about that
uh disown easy cuz I know this does
they're higher levels when you know when
I go inside the store I'm not going
inside the store looking for that budget
brand stuff I'm going in there trying to
knock it out the park so oh my joy now
I'm gaming on right now is the culet so
the cue later
what is it 9f so you know whatever the
highest level is on that I'm trying to
figure out because I'm gonna change the
one downstairs
and when I'm changing downstairs I'm
gonna know if that's shown easy cuz I
think disease a top is top he's always a
lot of TV talking again a chance out the
door chalice he's saying the c8 LG has a
Beretta a brighter screen in the c9 and
better HDR but only 60 Hertz hip-hop is
back no no no don't get to Xena dok2
text via text me and yeah we talk to you
about that anyway this why tell people
if you got if you got an environment
where you have a lot of windows right if
it rooms really like bright I always
liked my old Samsung KS it does more
outbreak much d9 right now yeah what I
got that's the one I got to but the c9
is great because you've got g-sync if
you wanna use a PC hundred twenty or its
variable refresh rate and the thing is a
pasta bro right and when it comes to
pure attention to detail and contrast
block the blacks and the it's just you
can't top and all that for stuff like
that yeah well I got I got an old let
amount of the houses I got it does this
over there but what what I what I'm
using right now see I don't have when
you see me doing those videos I don't
have a bunch of windows lights like that
because I make sure I got blackout
shades I got this so my room can get
absolutely pitch dark
so I don't worry about that aspect of it
my aspect is I'm worried about the hdmi
2.0 I'm worried about the Hertz going
for because a lot of people don't
understand these new consoles going
forward is giving you things that some
of us won't be able to take advantage we
talk about that later
yeah but your history brother shot auto
shot get beating us off you're a [ __ ]
with this rel switch at IP is live I'm
rubbing my nips I'm so excited I gotta
ask you this because this is something
we need you [ __ ] I always see you
reps that veto baby you're there so we
gotta talk about it you know to me I
think it was so ahead of its time I'm a
huge obviously I'm everybody know I'm
switch gang coming in hot and all that
good stuff but the leader to me it still
has still features that the switch does
not have like party chat the trophies
the online like I would be able to talk
to my playstation dudes in the same
party chat like two games away from
owning the full library Wow what you
missed them oh my god it's sword art
online so I don't know hmm but um talk
that Vita me why don't you wait for in
the box brand-new I'm not captain going
to mighty NATO see them all we know we
don't about the Vita is ahead of 100
legs the first one not the not the remac
one that doesn't Orion yes my first one
yes you know the first games don't have
true analog sticks doubling a lot yeah
but you know what killed the Vita was
proprietary memory cuz we all know that
we don't have you know not lackluster
first party game stuff like
but the Vita is so special with me man
because I could play all my PSone
classics a complete in yes mm-hmm
sit down in bed and you're playing like
you know Castlevania on you know uh yeah
but you've never had that a dead tech
enjoyed for it yeah bro this joy the
soul the only thing the only thing Adam
dodo
I like the you find this anywhere okay
this is the PS Vita TV you can use a
dual shock yeah this thing right now go
look them up on eBay they would they
would discontinue that Walmart for two
dollars okay now as you can crack it you
can throw everything on this little
thing through HDMI which you can't play
games on TV unless you have this right
man pick this up this is great that's
what some it's a little to the Vita mag
look and the switch okay this thing is
great but not stand still in the
catchable joy cause yes we know you out
here listen I want to say some of the
switch the switch is lacking themes
seems to last like two days ago the apps
is weak I can't talk to nobody about
friend what's the purpose of the friends
list and you can't even message of me
like you women they don't get when they
lose then you can get all of that but
that's what I Blaz like that's what hurt
me that Vita didn't win because I felt
technology wise they were so great you
know I'm saying you had the remember
you've had the remote play they debuted
let's be let's be real here
Nintendo needs to let saudi make they
were a hardware because they actually
have up-to-date features on something
that came out like ten years ago
the the switch don't even have literally
is just a console like when it first
came out i thought you know how like
their name will pop up on your screen
like I thought you could click on that
and go to their profile because I'm yes
I click I was like oh that's right I'm
on it I will say this for the switch the
only thing I gotta give them over the
Vita where I think obviously they got
the Nintendo DS and all that but we care
front blaze like the dual the fact that
they had the dual shifts the triggers
and you had the analogues in as a button
so now you have full console
functionality and Nass was saved them
but if you look at the feature set Vita
was superior like Vita still had it's
just that from a console gaming
perspective you can port easy because
you had every button use you didn't have
to do the tricks with the you know the
lower left hand and only the thing is
they don't Pokemon being no no I'm they
don't have Pokemon that's why it's fair
GTA and a strong Pokemon yeah monster on
no I get you know you're making it the
right Pokemon to thing that so any
handheld anyway so let me go wrap up
because we got a lot of show but I wanna
you know we did the hell we did the
history real quick but I just gotta ask
what's up quick super tada super chat so
so is my TCL 4k $300 TV in the bushes in
don't you okay act like you don't che
people on the hard way
TCL is a good entry budget for know just
save your money and buy some good people
o going best rate away chill out just
save you some money and get a good TV so
you buy it once and be done with it
that's right no job done your joint not
a 10-minute joint look obviously you got
homies with a lot of fellow lords in the
world that we afraid of shut the Lord
meds shout out to a little bit cloud of
course loss on the revenue has been on
IOP it's been a long time but um just
want to start as far as the YouTube
channel and then your journey to getting
on both our GT podcasts and silac ass so
YouTube started off I remember plane I
want to give my love to little Jack me
Johnny
Oh Jack mo salut yes a little weapon
wheel press 200 left yeah yeah so you
know
last of all seems cool but I grabbed I
remember like playing games with madly
bad show you know yeah and he said yo
why don't you just do one if you think
it's so easy doing something like your
videos you know I make a channel and
from there like with the support like I
got love right away I just I literally
got love from Reb so much yeah he just
pushed that you know you give me little
shoutouts on Twitter or throw me in
videos and throw me like the podcast the
reason is all the cast are because I
forced it on the Kelly needle it's all
you know you don't like that he's like
King you don't want to do this court
this court listen I got a do weapon
we're late on the day and he hit me I
was like yo send a link to what some
call he's like yeah because we want
disco but no you know what got me into
youtuber stuff I gotta be honest with
Jack it's all you know like I want to
say Jack and Rev just pioneered my shed
they gave me I got viewers from both
sides I got I mean like a lot of people
we love so yeah I just don't want to
waste time talking about me this is your
moment
bro this is you we gotta celebrate you
the realm at the end of the day we see
what you doing out here at the end of
the day like I said we know what flag
your rep but mad cool dude always giving
back to the community always show a lot
and then
the thing that people don't know is like
yo you rock on every day I know we know
place is your joint but you got actually
you got PC you telling me what's the the
best call out the best TVs like your
tech game is serious you don't say so we
gotta celebrate your roses why you can
smell them so I gotta ask you though the
question that we ask all in the round
I need that top 5 video games or
franchises of all time I would say uh
Wow mmm pick a bunch of kids what's your
favorite don't say PS one two three four
I get to Castle yeah we doing games for
games honestly no in no order no order
Max Payne 3 I like the rocks covers yeah
yeah Max Payne 3 Dark Souls okay right I
gotta give it up so and then so called
Odyssey number 5 I'll give it to uh
number 5 I probably give it to honesty
lastly what's now the PlayStation people
are all coming together should we revoke
his access that's a gamer right dude
exactly that's true game at all
and lastly now I already know what I
already figure what you go say as far as
the the brand but I knew that you not
figure now yeah I need to know so great
your greatest console of all time number
one stays at 360 just only one she's got
to pick one all generations what's the
best you don't know what to think it's
gotta be which one it's gotta be it it's
gotta be the Xbox one
you know clip that right yo and did
people give it this basically can look
if you guys are gonna lose that
PlayStation citizenship over that is
love yo the chat is cloudy right of Rome
- all right before it before I got a ask
though why ps2 over ps4 it's just you
gotta throw the stones in there number
one number two with the amount of like
everything was an exclusive back then
you got an abandoned right but wasn't an
exclusive because it will actual an
exclusive was an exclusive because
Nintendo couldn't run it no no
regardless of what the fact was the GTA
grant Grand Theft Auto all those games
final fantasy those were all exclusives
like you know I mean so that's I just
remember having so many games to play so
many options to play all the online I
did with that game need for speed and
the soul calms and all that mom I just
got to give it to that platform because
literally I stayed with the ps2 so long
yeah but waiting to hold a hold or
Shalit the carry how early the to Dodger
he said man if you don't get blazed out
of here it's easy to PlayStation 4 y
also need a Sinbad Kenny I'm sorry that
is there something wrong people being
bored of the night oh here we go you
ain't get out of the play session
commune you get voted out of the IO
because you're not but realtor that most
of the chat is which you blame there
like place a shot to bachcha Lords of
gaming down there so out to Philly ego
he said yo that's his number joint ever
qwv not a chat is really writing what
you know is they okay okay put the money
on those piss it's really closed ps4 in
case these ps4 is broken
so many great games great experience
same Star Wars spider-man and good hold
on time out there we fall off and lose
one because the other one was part of
PlayStation 3 way through the Last of Us
so uncharged blood-borne bout to go to
Sean you can say Uncharted because dad
started on placed it so we you can
really say surprising to be honest it is
it is yeah you young bucks are you
struggling over there checker oh you
need to stay I want that day is gone I
see that's one of the games I definitely
want to end like okay so this summer's
gonna be a great summer for me like when
it comes to actually blowing the dust
off that that that jet engine and then
jumping into the games I'm definitely
gonna blow the dust off the jet engine
pause and I'm definitely gonna put on
that day is gonna you know a lot of
people got on my nerves at that days
gone yeah you got some people that was
saying it was good then you got some
dudes that was saying it was bad but
then I started listening to Xbox dudes
that dabble in PlayStation and they said
it was good you know that so I'm going
to definitely use their opinion because
sometimes certain Sony dudes make their
expectations for um like Double A titles
too high mm-hmm right and don't give it
you don't give it a chance to breathe
then I like the way Sony understands it
okay our fan base is dis we see a
certain metric and certain core and they
they cultivate it and it goes forward
and becomes another good title when he
gets to part two
you know it's like connection of my PA
right
well you know do not disrespect stated
acacia oh yeah oh man a letter game wait
dude do you see that that game looks
better than most like end of the
generation games
oh yeah what happened to rise some room
and that game what was he using it in
the beginning backs
both of these consoles what the hell was
he using right well they was using the
priciest engine right man right was a
basement but what's the order was it but
no what the what the hell happened
cuz you see now you sort of see this
certain game is it after the fact there
look at it and he don't look as good as
those two game those two games is
probably yeah they must have
expectations boy that's cuz after they
came out to game it let's make this
legging look good they made it look good
was like all right let's put features in
do we part yeah can we do anything with
the game I mean aim-down-sights that's
about all I think rise in Sun Rise and
the order of sequels I think man I
waited the whole generation and I didn't
get sequels to two of the games that
actually made me play those consoles
like that that really irritated the hell
did you see how the werewolf transformed
like when he came the first time he
transformed I said cuz I'm a howling
fool so I loved the movie to howling so
I my mom I saw that was like this is
this is the first great representation
of a werewolf transformed on on the
screen for me because I wasn't playing
blood-borne and stuff like that so you
know but this game is I'm a shoe to do
but you know I definitely see we are we
have almost 350 people and hit that like
button man let's get that above 300 pop
on the end of the show keep in mind if
it's above 300 I had to wear overalls
this is the last show this has to get
over 300 or I dodged a bullet
the drunken ninja - awesome job
PlayStation 2 has way more variety than
PlayStation 4 o shah-e buns is still
coming back at he said did not be second
row first if that wasn't that wasn't in
color we talked about blaze of 35 how
dare you say you're a gamer I mentioned
and mention I guess he meant not mention
I'm in Mike Tyson's punch-out and contra
contra yeah he gave it up he gave it up
to a sense man but look man all hold on
$5 chip a chap from kid smooth radiant
dawn and cry tech both blew the budget
on super bit so bit G theta decay to is
an actual zombie apocalypse in game days
gone is just another action game you
can't even die in bad some respect on
damn anyway but look we got a lot of
show to get into tremendous gaming
history all that good stuff let's get to
the poll get to the topics get this
going last week poll results are into
the question with the latest rumors and
insurgency regarding the Xbox Lockhart
what would you prefer the device to
become the winner of the three-way ILP
poll at 50 percent of the vote was yes a
dedicated for teraflop console coming in
at second place kind of close 32 percent
hybrid handheld switch like device and
in last place at only 16 percent was the
I don't care because we all know
Lockhart don't exist group shout out to
all the lords who are participating in
the poll Lord saw how do we feel about a
dedicated yeah I'm with that because if
you looking at the the PlayStation 5 now
with two skews I don't think the
difference between those consoles is
gonna be more than 50 bucks so a lot car
coming at a school 300 and still offer a
lot of those next gen experiences I
think it they think think that's what it
is
you already know yes we got so we gonna
get right into a man I know which are
here for
let's get let's get to it so long yeah
set it up
PlayStation 5 reveal the future of
gaming had arrived man we had to wait a
week when uh it came down on Thursday I
mean the future of gaming is very very
spot on because nothing there had
released a first out of my blog I saw I
got some stuff I talked about I put it
in chat oh but look we got to get it to
a managed but big reveal tons to talk
about so let's start with PlayStation
nations old blade 4k who was in the line
reaction stream with us while we were
going through it man so now we've got a
couple of days to sit back on this thing
off this reveal tell me how you feeling
blaze somebody standouts and overall the
show where you're at what place are we
doing positivity right now Oh deep it's
a while stand out number two
ratcheting rank yeah that miles morales
instant nyquil blaze what you did was
some of them did you didn't like the
strawberry game in the middle like well
you know like no not right though so no
bug snacks that's that was literally
they're almost the whole show what's
going on here the little o the house
marking the fob which you don't mean you
win on that one is not buying I can't
say he's not gonna buy it
he'll buy it he'll play for about 40
minutes and they're just like no okie
brother to the side are not same as of
right now the potential of it is of
course I got a
- right throughout and see if it
continues to do what to do but as far as
potential he's gonna purchase his games
in the beginning that game was gonna
come in the middle with some other stuff
that's coming out and that game gonna
slide all the way under the radar into
the bushes and tried to fence you know
that game was never gonna get played by
his fingertips and all his gameplay any
continued blaze give it a super Philly
go like what you like but fanboys either
stop acting like this show was much
different than the Xbox the inside Xbox
third-party show full cartoony games
hashtag same energy how you feel that
we've missed slow-mo slow-mo
the word of the day for sixty Hertz TVs
is screen tearing my bad slow-mo so we
got two dollar super chef from Philly
ego sure was good but keep the same
energy i blaze what's going on here
what's the same energy I don't know what
what does it mean directed towards blaze
so continue basically yeah oh wait it
was the project what is it something I
really don't even recall their name I
just remember scene took like ten years
to make ten so let's see how long it
takes from the best you've got man you
miles are just going in Photoshop gone
now good see you blade let the man talk
[Laughter]
it was a lot of filler filler passion
project game I don't agree with all
those games this is the difference
between me and other Sony
see here that every game I saw it was
incredible facts well that were
incredible were incredible and then and
then acting the day they stamped the
bottom line it showed the console yes
yes yes all right now they showed the
console with the disclaimer at the
bottom the disclaimer at the bottom of
the console is finals hold on let me say
let me pull that up because I send that
to you guys but let me double look at
that it says final specs - final
specifications are subject to change
without notice
yeah I know they don't design and design
specs and specifications or so so you
have an issue you think that something
may happen
what are we implying cake hmm a lot of
his language is definitely are foreign
to us right because okay so the
specifications on the design okay so
then what you're saying is what you're
shown is much we might not get or what
you're saying is what you talked about
about the spec sheet of the systems is
what we might not get and then you just
make sure that you put that disclaimer
this so legally we can't hold you to
your words so technically you're trying
to be transparent we're putting a veil
over I had I don't like the language in
in the bottom of it and they put it down
there as a fine print like Gill but it
was dead oh you know like mousse on 360
Dale you know what I meant everything
we were gonna take everything so I'm not
trusting their intentions when they when
they put that is it what do they mean by
that and you know that's what I wanted
to bring you know to the realm later but
yeah yeah but you know back to show I
didn't even know him thank you for
bringing attitude I just saw it no real
quick so we got a supercar from well so
chose the place I should now filter
Ratchet and Clank look good in horizon
zero dawn but I don't recall seeing
dates for those of you you know what
we'll meet but let's put some in on -
something's in the channel that's a shot
definitely put it in there on the
audience on gaming beyond the box match
will be hood the homies
bomb a fork nation all those guys man
formation rolling shout out to the
longest fingers in the game a Chalmers
being crazy
what else do perch are from Jonathan be
have you all seen have you all seen the
console size comparisons the psy is
about the size of two doors a two-door
Honda Civic has not my playstation you
know you're actually going to talk about
the here a little bit so definitely to
what Miss Jean Jean with me Tina looks
amazing right through Skyward Sword yeah
I'm gonna kick with the sideways go of
reference what's up kid we yeah no I
love that yeah yo I can't give you that
lofty praise yet you know for saying
that is one of my greatest games that I
love you know I didn't see that from it
it looked like cameo but a little bit
different but let's just see but listen
I told you before a lot of those games
won't get purchased by me because they
don't have a service so I can dabble in
dip and son now I told you when I saw
the digital version gems dance moves
Ryan is definitely you know
Pinocchio's to Phil's but Geppetto and
he's definitely being manipulated into
the area of all digital now when that
happens they need a good service to get
you to have that hummingbird effect and
I want PlayStation now to do that and I
think we're going to get that I think so
okay no now shout out to the suicide
King finalist which at best part of the
show is when Jim says no one plays all
game Jim Jim no one plays all game Ryan
opened the show with two generations of
old GTA 5 ok you go at it right down
there you got can't daddy recognize
blaze we have stitch along we have
stitch at I think King is right about
the 2021 release date and we have snow
mobile back slap with the fire also but
Chad spider-man Miles Morales alone will
sell PS 5 this fall game or table well
slow-mo back slap a game with xx 5 baht
sells Xbox is a we got a
Sloman dumbest I'm not gonna slow me
down the same answer slow real quick
how can you outsell something that you
don't have more than it doesn't matter
that you if you sell out out
yeah let's say you have two million you
bring two million to the show right
you sell two million but if Xbox brings
four million to the show you can't
outsell something that you have nothing
of that's gonna be the question whether
or not the stock is there and you know
what so Moe I look my my super chat was
read extremely late because you guys are
such in the conversation like how you
gonna argue with the man that has like a
lot of time in real estate retail as a
whole
well you and he was like well how much
time designer can listen we go get it
but look I do whatever that's not gonna
get into that whole door holder whatever
cuts in a window homie with Erica we got
a $2.00 subtract from CAD daddy I tell
you the difference
gameplay in God's nap daddy this now you
be investigating the judge yo shout -
Eric cuts for the win as I move um kena
was the sleeper of this show
keep it up our face salute you know
those was the one that looked like this
guy rhetoric lost at it like some
pictures on the little blog verb looks
yes Elmo says you don't have X you don't
know Xbox will be able to produce more
units your favoritism does not create
manufacturing you okay so you we all we
could go off is the facts the facts is
Sony's the only one that's actually said
that they've had is they're having
issues with that Microsoft has its are
you gonna say Microsoft's lying and
Sony's not lying
alright Tony did insane Sonny didn't say
they had problems sony toys they all
gonna be able to from the rip that
they're going to be limiting stock on
purpose they told you because they don't
know if that you know what what the
world looks like that was the excuse
right whatever they told you they
we'll be a limited stock are they trying
to say or we're gonna fake you out I
really honestly believe that they're
telling the truth on that right on that
part right there
Microsoft has told you that the system
will come out this [ __ ] and that's all
they said so at no point in time did we
feel that they were going to limit stock
or say that you won't be stock available
right I believe stock will be available
and also believe that the stock
available for the PlayStation will be
sold in limited quantities and then next
year when they fully ramp it up if it
doesn't launch this year they will do a
full launch next year but if they do a
limited launch this year you're only
gonna have a certain amount that's gonna
get sold you can't I'll sell something
if you don't have it don't matter if you
was by these adopted they're definitely
selling they're definitely selling
there's no denying that call any game
stock call any Walmart there's no Xbox
or Playstation Blaze's defense we know
there's no place to face there so let's
say that the MPD's have reflected he's
absolutely 100% right it's true I mean
you do have you know a hundred and what
is a would 3535 systems out there and
you not you don't have one game that
actually sold 135 numbers oh here we go
I'm gonna say this we just found out
that game Pass has 90 million
subscribers right so towards your
metrics that game pass is a universal
thing on xbox right right if they're
making just as much money does the
console sales and that metrics that
you're holding on to does that even
matter anymore you talk about but it
matters for one company
the company that doesn't have an
alternative way of making money they
only can make money one way
Microsoft has showed you that a would be
a pedestrian with it that means they're
able to use the left hand and the right
hand with Sony is only left-handed I
hear I hear where you're going I got it
we got off you five Canadian dollars to
protect with his curly then to all the
room we need to pool our money together
and buy that $1,000 patreon level so
that you get that IOP crusts at it on
his chest let's go strawberry man was
running for k120 using that SSDs
healthiest patreon healthiest super
chair I've ever seen Wow thank you
brother like my god it's like it like
y'all are interrupting me at every
moment first like it's crazy
nah we take the rough all that smoke 391
me king attic we all saw we all know
when it was four or five people in here
and you have no idea like we use that we
used to get mad at our friends but we
hit some of right after the podcast why
won't you in that shadow saying Bobby
you ain't watching my podcast it's beef
it's because listen god I know really
stop messing with people if you're not
supporting me if you're not trying to do
listen I'm not telling you to sit around
and watch the whole daggone show yes
just pull come in say what's up or look
don't ask me but if you're a friend of
mine and I dropped Carol west every week
and you ask me oh did you do an Ironman
statue if you're standing in front of me
on my Mac all goddamn us Mac you if
you're standing in front of them I smack
you so but that's an easy way to get
blocked and disliked and then thrown in
the bushes because
that means you're not going to loads of
gaming down there when I went to loads
of gaming that meant I actually had a
tear in my eye for how hard the law
kognito and the Lords of gaming that net
zoos are working it is a website that
rivals IGN now if you think I'm joking
just go pull up to the website and look
at it and if I'm lying I'm dying trust
me when I'm telling you this we rival
them if they're sourcing us we rival
them
no reason hasn't been seen yet and when
we see you can't unsee what it is a
given database sleuth all you ask it all
right a lot of writers it didn't shout
to all my boo we see all my boy macho in
a channel you'll get that super Jeff
will be so we have menu to Xbox series X
does what PS 5 don't run at 4k 60 frames
per second y'all busy shut up don't we
have good you put the crust in the chat
for Lord
Alex PSX welcome to the little brown boy
yo shout out the we do know will so we
have we have Alex and then we have
we have lower echelon 7 the dark with
the file I'll switch at Phil please we
make max curse of brotherhood and
acquire both the soul we Alex oval and
bright memory which looks better on
Ceres X at any ps5 game and we'll put a
room right yeah we got that oh you know
first off I want to you know thank
everyone for being in here you know we
we got almost 400 people hit that like
button if you guys don't mind we got to
fight out super chair from gaming for
teh been beating this drum for over six
months xbox whoa outsell the PS 5
slow-mo with Xbox has has the stock to
meet the demand this holiday has Jack
sorry so let's get some hashtag sorry
slo-moes in that chat actually read will
Mesa preach can't grab our rolling pins
unless let's go hey I thought that you
guys read that because Keith was having
a heart attack for the real challenge
real discipline we got a $10 from sweaty
Schmitt tell them Lord King Lord neck
IOP Kos and last word they aren't
straight great is Lou no show just
finish me because I got so much love him
because when we will be at the shows and
we're doing our coverage he's in every
video like you'll keep going Lords keep
doing yo y'all giving us more coverage
in all these other groups and we do it
hits me it definitely I hope you
community is slowly uh helping us make
that super our IOP community slowly
helping us make that super spear bomb
that's what's going on rollin I'm just
telling you it just looks professional
Thank You Rob Dave's right my boy my boy
was in a chat shout out to hide 13 he
was nice to admin shout the dizzy he
came to me with the vision we all
collaborate and it was it and just put
something together that we proud of it
it's good it's good to see you flourish
Michelle too squirrely dance Canadian to
Ella
one more time $1,000 so cake can get
true
the squirrel I really like right now
I'll get you the link will me to the
pager that is the final here make a
sovereign wrote it they don't do your
song do me a favor
we gotta be hold up we gotta be
realistic huh if something like that
were to happen word you to go through
how to making sure I don't want to put
that kind of info out like the Joker but
let me tell you something each and every
last one of you dude nobody pulling up
that how they do the thousand one don't
think just keep on yeah we got a bunch
of them we have okay no we have stitch
with the file a super chat if the stock
market bless me next week King you get
in that tat we got to fight out a super
chair from tipis son has sex sorry saw
most Sullivan though generate one to
seven
goodbye volcano hi is written by Kate
gray who posted Steve Fisher child
pornography on coach are on Kotaku looks
crash and came for trash should not be
on
sorry we ain't going into that man but
definitely appreciate the Canadians
Coralie hey King you throw and [ __ ] on
my piece PVC
oh that's the statues he was talking
about oh no not actually I'm just
letting people understand exactly what
PVC is versus natural stop using the
word statues and we got a new member we
got the qtr grizzly welcome to welcome
the Lord to the realm
Wow get in there let's change this
rhetoric fall let's get back to what we
have for games super chat according to
Sony fans 30 frames per second is the
new 60 frames oh right yeah I got all
the games that everybody's capping for
let's get blazed guys bars off for the
most part I just want to ask one last
question before we move the addict
everyone else which was I know when you
were last room with us I know how the
energy was in the room I know we felt
the way right with certain things but I
know shout depressed I'll shout the coal
freedom duels I know you went over there
and then you say okay you said [ __ ] I
actually felt better about it afterwards
right so my question to you blaze is
what change your perspective after
sitting back a little bit and saying you
know what not it's not as bad as I may
have initially felt yeah you know first
of all watching the the uploads the
better quality of oh yes yes that'll
change your perspective right away xanax
I'll give you that it shot out is a god
full looking way better when I splatter
yeah
not fall look like like a 368 of man
yeah look like a PlayStation game yeah
that's exactly wouldn't look like all
those games at that show look like
PlayStation games you had a mix it good
and you know mix of bad there was a show
this is the guy with the green
background okay and you notice when you
get out your chair forms the eggs I mean
I'm just saying I'm
is in your heart you know go away I'd
like a book an x-ray dude listen I'm
telling you visually you're giving off a
different message than what you say it
verbally and it's a consciousness
speaking what your mind doesn't want to
articulate about you I'm here for you
intervention this is what it is when
every year and this shoe gut tells you
something go with your gut like if
you're walking down the alley and you
see a strange figure down there and yet
God says don't go in there don't go in
there so you watch the show and your gut
told you it was wet right but then you
got around dudes that told you not it
was nice yo it was good so you know what
I do see it in a different man at this
point time so what it was is it was a
whack show and it wasn't a whack show
from a perspective of the games were
whack it was a wax show from the
perspective of the height that was led
into it right we all are a prisoner of
this height train is going forward now
they showed the console I'm happy for
that that saved the whole show for me
right I knew I know basically what was
going to be there and I'm and I'm happy
to show both but people don't know
little things like showing the digital
version that's you putting your foot
forward daring Microsoft across that
line because Microsoft has been holding
in their back pocket the Lockhart right
right and even they've been dangling
this thing in front of you but you just
don't understand how they're gonna use
it against you so what Sony said is I
dare you I dare you pull it out now we
show two hours so I dare you
strategic move I actually like I think
that was the one of the most underrated
shout to Forte he's attached and we
talked about every last night that was
the thing of the show that was easy I
mean you know the games was the game and
you know the console but that to me was
a very subtle yet powerful competitor
yes yes I use form
Babli this la carte isn't going to be a
scaled-down version of yes yes so now if
you're if you're a consumer and you're
looking at both systems okay all digital
mm-hmm
and if look at the Lockhart it's not is
not cheaper right
I mean if it's more expensive than that
all digital robot that's a problem the
problem I don't think I agree that's
that's not going to be the case my
patients are different but that question
to you guys is do you think that they're
gonna have an all digital with the exact
same amount of space or do you think
they're gonna use that going people of
the poll question attic love it okay so
in my opinion the PlayStation is going
to be the exact same thing right it's
going to be the exact same PlayStation
just digital with a bit of an odd page
with a double to hogr they didn't they
didn't show you a solution like
Microsoft showed you a solution for
their memory there's a reason why their
SSD isn't some special SSD is a reason
for that so is in line with their memory
expansion units they say giving you and
that you can expand it right so yeah but
the PlayStation has locked you into this
proprietary thing right no but there is
they for my understanding because it's
such a special SSD but they work it with
soft specific partners right that yeah
they're that they have to be approved so
to speak right that level of speed out
obviously they don't exist right now
yeah okay me I'm gonna say this wildstar
right um you gotta be approved for when
I start to launch my spaceship all right
so it doesn't exist right now but when
we do give you the approval you can make
the specification to your spaceship to
meet ours it's gonna be a faster version
of that and
okay well is there anything wrong with
that no there's not but you guys are
making for you so you're saying you have
to go through Marcus off to change your
upgrades right that's the difference
Sony said you can buy it off Amazon you
can buy it from anywhere but don't have
anything available to do that oh you yo
you can buy my car anywhere when I give
them the specifications but at the
moment right now you can only buy that
car here so it don't make any sense like
what you're saying is you're available
to do this but you can't do it right so
it's not up to par if you're not gonna
be made that can do it like $5,000 we
gotta see yeah we don't we don't price
structure look
clutch mount to $2 which at PS 5 sad
coming in hot yeah all right cool so
look man let's get right to it
so Dee show you know you had a lot to
say live we've had a couple of days to
reflect what are you feeling sir about
the show it was a good show but at the
end of the day it's just like the
Microsoft show they they kind of
promoted this to what it wasn't they
said the future of gaming which they did
like okay there was good stuff in there
I like the ratchet and clay like the
demon so it's not the biggest fan of of
horizon zero dawn so I'm gonna say
that's trash because I'm I'm the mayor
of addict world so that's what I'm gonna
say about that but you know I'm gonna go
back I'm gonna try the first one let's
see how that goes but at the end of the
day I wanted gameplay
and people oh they gave you game point
no they gave me Ratchet and Clank
gameplay that's all so what you want to
say bro you told Nina discord with the
Sony poll news that it was a great show
oh it was a great show
did I not start this statement with no
no no no no Jota Jota Jota but I not say
it was a good show did I not say did I
place dinner this conversation good you
could see you look it was a good show
it's just like gameplay and it liked a
lot of games that I would be interested
in
I wanted to see Demon Souls and I saw
Demon Souls but then when it went on to
the next one I was like is that it like
I wanted to see more on it but I didn't
right horizon zero dawn you know I get
it the game is probably in like mid
development but you mean to tell me
people told me that games coming out
next year but they have no gameplay no
I'm not buying it you mean to tell me
demon souls are supposed to be a launch
town but no gameplay no I'm not buying
it so because of the lack of gameplay on
certain games you have less confidence
that these games are going or no it's
not that I don't have less confident
like look what those games come out is a
reputation of what those games come out
we're talking about this events you know
there's no there's no ground where you
were you convinced me that these games
do not have gameplay that they could
have shown mm-hmm they call it they
chose not to show them when they called
the future of gaming they mean literally
the future the future gaming is the
future of gaming apparently a CGI
horrid card Nino was
not in this stays safe microsoft view
was wrong for not show a heatwave yeah I
was the only one in here saying we liked
it I was like nah didn't show a lot of
gameplay with a hold on hold on we got
my bro
the dodge the dodge Knight though the
crest of the dodge knight has entered
the realm bronze members salute Dodge
van much love we supposed to beat out at
e3 hopefully thank you so we got a $20
super trap from all-or-nothing love to
show guys keep it up definitely
appreciate the support that's all guys
oh man we've wait behind I apologize for
that approach Mario hell blade will blow
our minds in July our lawful C project
Mario there Bobby hey Lulu and we have
Jonathan beautify like super everything
that every everyone just make sure you
bring a forklift when you go through the
stores you can actually get the giant
system get that picture so we got we got
a $10 super chart from egos fan 76 I'm
not a football person I don't know if
that's relevant or not no reason for me
to buy a PS 5 day one until late 2021 no
clear messaging for specs on the s UK's
with pricing lack of launch games and no
Dillon o dates not clear on backwards
compatible and smart little view first
party games look are 30 frames you know
what everyone put onto something in that
chat bag because I agree everything he
said I agree and this is not an attack
on on PlayStation as a whole its attack
on the message that they have provided
us which your dodge you got use a
special emojis bro you know I'm saying
you know so in the realm now you got
special emoji to contain so we got a
$2.00 super chart from young boy GA a
[ __ ] I don't even know I'm not gonna
even try it again and say look coming
out this year where the gameplay
hopefully that gameplay will be July
there's no hopefully July it's gonna be
that just hopefully the game comes out
this whole shot though we got a $5 super
choc from Kid smooth
I heard that cut content but had room to
show struck
yeah okay so kid when it came to that
cut contact right it was 32 to 35 games
and my theory is all those transitions
that you saw was actual games that were
going to be put into because it's
probably like 20 minutes of if you take
those transitions out of the game of
this of the show that they can actually
I filled it with those games it was I'm
really upset that I didn't see Mac 3
okay let's get elevator filled tonight
I can't wait for the men are you gonna
call them
I can't wait for the PS Bob what did
well me John about oh no no wait first
let's get before will we did we get but
I mean Jack and we're gonna pay five
soon thank you 2023 then we have Alex
with the files which at bucks and axe is
gonna be goat is gonna reach 95 Medicaid
will me all with the crippled two dollar
super check done oh no sorry I don't see
[Laughter]
the five dollar super check everything
was captured on PS 5 hardware on this
show nothing was captured on Xbox and
you know you're a hundred percent right
that's why all that junk was 30 frames
came out it says July is gonna be fired
he said that he let's be real him I've
said that what the like the jab jab jab
and that's like
leave it at the last minute the the fact
that he knows that okay I want to
appreciate everyone coming out we have
almost 420 people and you're definitely
that like you guys don't mind and if
value
let's subscribe yeah do that so let's
solve let's get to it man home you know
how you know how you felt initially you
know sad my dad you got a couple days to
sit on it playstation reveal you know
future of gaming overall where you at
now with this show so just like blaze I
you know going back you watch everything
in 4k you able to appreciate things a
lot better so um I still give it the 7
that I gave it because um for me I
thought it was safe and I mean safe in
that all the big bangers they show what
stuff we knew was coming you know what
kind of reminds me of saw like when when
Microsoft did that III when Sony bailed
out of e3 like we was like they played
it safe and they didn't go for the kill
see this year like I've always made that
analogy that Microsoft this year right
was it ever moments Microsoft was not
bothering anybody off to the side and
Sony would combine just Muslim and slap
him in the face
like it like it would they would keep
the boot on the neck for the sake of
doing it when there was no reason to and
and this time I was like they had an
opportunity to come like to come out and
be like you know this is really the
reason why you're upgraded ps5 next year
and it was safe where they gave you what
we knew was coming right the the most
exciting like outta left field stuff was
the mountain Rolla stuff alright and
we'll talk more in depth about that
nobody was expecting spider-man game so
soon and honestly the the sad the sad
was the the horizon Gran Turismo arm
Ratchet and Clank all stuff we knew was
coming it was great to see it but I
thought we were gonna see honestly I
thought we were gonna see I thought they
were inaudible a trailer a god war
trailer like 1 or 2 new IP
just to be like I didn't think it would
be God war but I did alright hold all
game before they say let's go will me
hood sorry King Neil meant
for king who did I received a
notification yes oh please because they
act like it's official good to you sir
no just whoa give you guys updates on
that the next couple days yeah and see
I'm logged out so I would have to go
through you can do that alright so
that's my thing like I was just like it
was it was fine but it was safe in a way
that Tony hasn't been saved before like
Sony just like I said they would mush
Microsoft just for the sake of doing
that I bully them and now it seems like
they're reserved I mean and that says a
couple of things to me right it says to
me they do know it did go through they
go through I see now
34 patrons and it definitely went
through go look at the actual iron Lords
podcast like the most yeah oh I got I
got that occasion I am so happy we are
in quarantine right now and know like
whatever coop all is do open up patreon
yeah the funny thing is when we put that
down I was like could somebody refund
him
we got a respect for King I asked you
before he did that would you willingly
do something like this at the end of the
day I'm a man of my word right so I
listened what the Spartan say right you
go out on the shield laying on it right
no you know what it's definitely gonna
happen the cameras definitely gonna be a
full case you gonna see my nipple that's
gonna be members only King members only
if you are a member of the realm or in
your patreon will you be able to see
that if you're not all 400 of you guys
will see absolutely see this right here
you see this look look watch me this is
what you gonna see just for clarity the
patreon tier is called ILP for life
solves beautiful word says again Lord
King is a man willing to do anything for
the Advancement of the I love podcast
this level of patronage gets you a live
stream oh we got language in there this
level of patronage gets you a live
stream tattooing of the ILP logo on the
chest of Lord King watch in amazement as
lord King bears his burly chest to the
world and cries like a cat in heat as he
proves his lifelong devotion to the isle
end up doing is will let will live
stream it to will be hooding and then
afterwards we'll put it for members only
it's going to be on July 2nd which is my
birthday oh so that's the day that I
will go under the blade and will me
you'll be at PAX next year
curly down to us with that King you're
welcome we'll put up the crest y'all for
us Robert Olson welcome to Lord bronze
thank you so much lower brother salut
and then we have there will become an
again what no no
with the $2 super chat took a minute for
the payment to go through I'm sure it
did now so wait we have sa long wait we
got a few that we missed it jumped us
okay King you're welcome
then we got I am Mike welcome to the to
the to the brown put up the mic then we
have kids move we got super chat tattoo
you're supposed to be defending me I
swam in July you ever seen these
PlayStation cats so broke they on social
media begging their girls to buy I don't
want you to get the ink King say you can
always say that's what you can always
say say about King King is a man in his
work oh you members I say thank you you
will be treated to the pain and I'm
gonna tell you right now you're gonna
see me just later and go to sleep
because I got my whole back done all
right let me tell you I'm not afraid of
the needle I'm gonna tell you this dope
how big you go get the it's gonna be
$1,000 worth that's exactly what I'm a
put down I'm giving him the thousand
dollars and say give me $1,000 worth of
detail and pain sir right here oh man go
to kress again so screw it $42 of attack
I love you king when my DVR is ready
please for black of X Erica everybody
eats heavy so you guys get a love like
this what Cape a tree let's go first
thing I want to say we have offer to
upgrade this aware 214 overalls jump to
shout out to Sparhawk with the welcome
to the round or 300 the Leapfrog the
Pocky challenge to do this yo yeah we
got the best community the national
treasure bro
Alex if they charge back the Lord should
slap them through the screen now that's
not how will we roll I will me that's
good money to soft ketchup it is no
element appeared the final super check
where was the white brick Sony supposed
to show with the asset with the Saturday
and we have Mariano and Kings Sony's
voice community is everything we roll as
a unit or we don't roll at all she's
gotta see that yo yo this is wow wow you
know it really matters jokes is funny we
did not expect this at all but I mean it
to really any in its we love that we get
is it's very eye-opening like it really
is man oh no it's Alex get ready for
divinity old Monday addict so you'll
shout out to press Dortmund salute oh no
blows Alex hilarious Wow Wow just keep
coming in hey you gotta shave you gotta
get the day here for that class Jay
welcome Lord bronze put up democracia oh
we got agra got a Buddha this is Wow
I love you guys I did that it's been a
very joyous occasion for you Oh
the show has gone down you've had a lot
to say the robe has been waiting for you
on Nestle where you at now you have some
days to resonate with no no I don't
flip-flop so um the show was a for right
and show was a for as a whole I hated
all the transitions because the - style
games that was supposed to be there
alright so let's start that off the rip
um I didn't see anything from police
station that couldn't be done on a
Playstation pro now what won't I just
just just interrupt you I want to play
the devil's advocate what was - the
people that said you can't have ratchet
clink without SSD in the PS 5 I don't
know that listen let me tell you
something I played ratchet and click the
one I have now and it's very amazing
looking and listen graphically yeah I
really didn't see that that far step up
oh right separating it from the
PlayStation Pro actually taking
advantage of the PlayStation Pro so what
what I saw was what y'all are getting is
an Xbox X X Box 1 X right let me tell
you why you're gonna Xbox one X because
X Box 1 X has been able to do 4k 30
frames per second your PlayStation
hasn't it has struggled the pro has
struggled checkerboarding wise to get to
4k true 4k right and 30 frames per
second now they're able to do it with
you so did I walk away super impressed
no actually I didn't because I believe
that they are fraud in you guys they are
frauding you in language they are
putting games behind a page
a wall that you can see because the
spider-man let's go to some of the
visually impressive games and the only
games of note at the show because
everything else was filler that happy
you will not purchase at all
so the the three game will the four
games of no will you say is the Gran
Turismo right the spider-man right the
Ratchet and Clank pie and the horizon
zero dawn right so we all know as
PlayStation owners we were only going to
get the Triple A bangers anyway so those
are the four triple a bang is that's the
only thing that we actually really care
about and we cared about console so in
doing that we know what we came there
for like sovereign says we just have to
bang bang we don't care about and I felt
that right I felt that from this show
now out of all of those games not one of
those games told me if optimized
properly the PlayStation Pro could not
do those games but what they told you
was this is not a brand new spider-man
game it's an upgraded engine for the
spider-man with Miles Morales as the
main character ps4 assets right
using PlayStation 5 assets I mean
PlayStation 4 assets you know up res
like every Xbox Series X game that's
coming to Xbox series X using the same
type of technology and it's locked
behind the PlayStation 5 now would it be
a disservice if that same game was
available to everybody on a Playstation
4 that's the question hold on because we
gotta get that's next time okay hold on
to that dog right but also how do you
feel when you saw the stuff like I saw
everything I saw there can be done on a
Playstation 4 if you see the fidelity of
a PlayStation 4 you understand what
you're dealing with you see none of that
stuff look better than the last of us -
none of that stuff look better than what
is it ghost of Tsushima so when you
using this is how when you mess up your
own so this is how you trip over your
own feet in the same last two months
that you show just show you got games
that come out that look better than the
station 5 are you gonna wait until they
to go forward to purchase anything so
that's why they got an 8 for me go for
the show two for one console and two for
the next card oh you did that's a that's
a strong school so basically just what a
recap right we're shown did not impress
you too much but the console coming you
know le n I needed that you needed that
because that gave you the confidence
that your this thing is coming out you
know that just let me understand okay so
you showed me a controller showed me a
logo before and I told you going into
the show I kept my same energy right if
they do not show a console this is a
fail you must show me an answer and I
want to interrupt you for a second King
because I'd be looking to some of these
reactions to a lot of people that said
they love the event and you look at
these reactions like there's no energy
there for like almost the whole show you
know obviously you got the Ratchet and
Clank energy the rise in energy the
demon souls energy but the rest is just
like it's literally a but on their
phones and and you know it's not another
but but the energy didn't start till
that wreath that were bill right like I
feel like a lot of people don't realize
how much the ps5 saved the whole show
right missile beta less this ask this
quite a BM again plays back in blaze if
in a hypothetical world if the console
was not revealed right and the show was
as is for games
would that have really seriously
diminished your score
the games were great but I don't care
what the games the games they show we're
great look if you look it says on the
website holiday launch 2020 you see if
you go to the places right now it's all
day long swim play so let's coming out
this year there's no it's clinics thanks
but you know remember Marcus often they
showed off the series of the first Xbox
one it's yes they showed what third
party games right Metro and initial of
minecraft in 4k and what come back to
that conference literally I was like
kill what did they show me mm-hmm
to make anything I just or a console you
remember that comment yes
remember that this was a lot of game
game game game game but there were
third-party games in Minecraft 4k I feel
that so I mean if you keep the same
attitude oh no no I keep them I'm
keeping the same energy remember I also
told you that all of those games are
intriguing on their own right intriguing
are they compelling for you to purchase
now the reason why I kept from Microsoft
at a point so much right now is because
of game pass right right they're giving
me a little listen you do you know what
it is to walk past your son's room and
say yo they just dropped our minecraft
dungeons download it I'm downstairs let
me know when you download it so we can
jump in and play together no money down
you know no money out of my pocket eh I
told him I said yo they just dropped no
man sky right my nine-year-old son the
level of savings that I'm achieving and
allowing him to broaden his gaming world
see before you was limited if you like
fighters you know use buying Tekken when
it came out right right and do you do
you want to know about an RPG you was
intrigued by it but you got $60 to throw
so basically King what you're saying is
what's offset on the livestream where
these games that they're intrigued we're
not gonna say they whack right no but
Radian treatable but what you're saying
is was solvers saying he made a good
point on the livestream which was that
what saves Microsoft in that sense is
that because those games are in-game
pass you are more likely is that which
choice I started to interact with what
was your you're more likely to interact
with them and you're more likely they're
more likely to get put pushed to the
forefront right because they knew that
they will spotlight smaller games on
game paths on and people just because of
the fact you have it you're gonna play
that game on the PlayStation
if those games come out near launch and
they don't have their big bang as at
launch those games will fill that void
and people like I said when you buy a
console if you don't have and the game
that you really looking for at launch
you're gonna fill it in with these games
and they may get played but if they if
those games on their own are not put
into something like PS now where where
they can be pushed to the forefront on
the PlayStation platform I think those
games die
ring at launch because all I had was
killed Oh that'll fall give me that we
have a pizza huh was that I really
thought I had myself the game was played
tudela super check just to let you know
I am HUD éxito the iron heart of Xbox
shout-out to King David you are Nicole
oh you get the Gordon Victor Xbox week
2019 III was better than this I look II
cannot be the first one to say that like
whatever this is this whole digital VIN
thing I want this gone let's bring back
III like what III was just more epic it
felt like every week I want to get my
balls off no no no I'm absolutely done I
don't want you guys to think that I
didn't like anything that was there
actually if you want to go game by a
game I'm one of those people that would
have try to everything that's there if
it's available to me to do so but if
you're talking about I'm on a 2 game a
year budget I'm just gonna go buy the
beggars and I'm just gonna wait for
horizon and drop and I'm gonna buy the
Ratchet and Clank I'm gonna buy no
commodities it's just that I don't think
that their underling titles get a chance
to shine if they don't have something
that's able to allow you to to touch so
what I saw from it was yeah that's nice
but at the same time I'm not giving you
no money for that yeah you're gonna get
money for Gran Turismo you're gonna get
money for those four titles but that's
money in the bank but the other ones
aren't let me get his ding like
standouts obviously the Morales we know
we're gonna talk about next
you know um Ratchet and Clank I thought
the tech in it was super fire you know
I'm saying and I don't even like those
type I'm gonna be right on me I don't
really rock with those joints but I love
the switching under mentioning to me
that was the first time I felt I learned
about the SSD tech cause even kid you
boy did you put this on Twitter or
something the Twitter it's just I just
really need to know because I'm well
your shout out the yo.hannes l for
joining the robe you get that only fans
King chest tattoo he said David get
ready
IOP shout out to will me hood and they
put a tattoo oh so they get that
exclusive livestream oh come on fish I
get JD Gable real quick play over the
files
what Xbox is done wrong this gent make
anything that team green announces that
not blow us away keep the keep the
receipt exactly the receipt and we are
gonna I'll finish my pizza you can get
just some support for the laws but I
have to admit I'm a fan of Miles Morales
as spider-man and Rosie O'Donnell but
that bug snacks though we got the ball
around joint we got that um project at
theater square joint I like that look
really cool um returned Oliva no can't
keep hating this and I'm not gonna buy
it the worst name ever but I hate today
don't like that name but me and blaze
the fire gun it had it feels like if you
look at it it still looks like a house
more game yeah yeah it's in 3d house
mark out to Arizona's best in podcast
when you to my god
um give me so that right there is the
sapphire butter that I like this
apparently the planet attacks you it had
to check you don't send like to hold the
chick whatever from alien or whatever
but she's in this plan I just love the
vibes of the spawn from prag matter the
joint was the arm the wild Ray had like
the spacesuit dude the wicked look like
a platinum game it's like okay yeah this
cat comedy this is the straight cut get
a cat in the girl it just look wild and
crazy i what grab a blaze I just I just
looked interesting I want to know what
is it's on my radar
that's all Jesse
he's on my rent so look that's it man I
just got to get to some things no man
and I got it I got to stand tall in the
room I know man King I've talked about
me adequate talked about it it's tough
but it's like we got to talk about the
energy in the hypocrisy mr. Dix and for
me you know I was told you know you
can't have kiddie games and passion
projects on your show that's not it
right yeah this is what the comment
section after the podcast called Simon
Expo
okay so then you know well I see a
plethora of those games right I was told
double skew approach would confuse
gamers you know said you know what it's
good it's confusing
yet I see a PlayStation 5 digital
edition or people confuse them you know
saying then I was told expect bang like
people were hitting me up in the DM like
oh you better get ready strapped in
you're saying it's coming you don't say
and the way I look at it I'm like 75% of
them games we're not on launch they had
20 21 release dates and I'm saying so
that's the other thing now as far as the
UM the SSD joint you know yet a Ratchet
and Clank but the thing that bothers me
is we learnt new verbage right designed
exclusively for PlayStation 5 right and
my thing is you've been touting speed
speed is the advantage this is the
balance system you know my thing is how
is it now that when digital foundry gets
to break down the exclusive title shot
the bill still well who we had on here
who gave it up to Sony he said look they
will have an advantage here right low
screens and in utilizing our first part
it's a first party to ratchet click its
first party horizon forbidden was its
first and we're getting 30 frames we're
children
where's the energy at so again let's
just put the fanboy hats away for a
second I understand if it got your logo
in the corner you're gonna can I get
that all I'm saying is there's a lot of
things that I've seen Xbox and other
companies doing and they got killed and
then I see this show and now nobody got
a problem with SKUs nobody got a problem
with come on what you call it kiddie
games no more again you've got to keep
the energy that's that's all I'm saying
far as me my only thing I thought the
show was silent I'm not gonna sit here
and act crazy like it was it that's
definitely the show the council was huge
it was Hugh that changed the energy of
the room we got that I actually think
the digital approach is smart I think
that's a great counter to see what the
hell Lockhart is doing now for me I
gotta act I got a few addicts world I
got I only care about me
that's a gamer excuse me that's cockney
those worthless yes disco very good you
got a year at a DM all only for my thing
at launch what am i buying at launch
only thing I saw was miles which we'll
talk about and the other one was carful
which actually looked better on a PC
gaming show we get it then later so
that's the only two everything else that
I'm interested all the joints I
mentioned that's fire to me
it's 2021 so my question to the people
who loved it is what are you excited for
at launch that that's where I show
because the third party show that we saw
for x marks that many people didn't like
you know saying we saw a lot of stuff
you know I'm saying at launch I say yo
your cooze is gonna be at launch this is
gonna be at launch that's gonna handle
infinite supposedly supposed to be at
lon Tony that's all I'm saying I just
love the feeling and I got no blaze we
talked about it off with your copper
system and you like yo I'm gonna
showcase but I would love to see if her
Ratchet and Clank is there we haven't
got confirmation on it that's all I'm
saying so it just we gotta keep the
energy the same not destroying this show
cuz it wasn't a bad show but we can't do
the hypocrisy stuff when Xbox is doing
an Ivy's anybody nobody got no problem
with SKUs and in kiddie games and all
the sudden let's just keep your shot the
arm what you call it picks up a shot
these guys that's all I'm saying but
that's how all our guys we're gonna have
to get these superchargers please
I got a manual a with the two dots at
switching worlds that gimmick who plays
like that Wow okay that we have
elemental people don't inject me
elemental peel with the $10 who beat at
Sony curated the games they wanted to
showcase what does it say about the
audience compared to Xbox promoting the
feed of 60 120 frames per second games
this sounds more hardcore than our scene
30 frames per second games
they're gay boys with the tool also it
has to move the King for being a good
sport great show
salut salut and then put the crust in
the chat Wow not strength to the round
nor bronze thank you so much put them
cress in the chat for the new low but I
got a $5 super sharp and Smitty submit
tell them Lord kognito my fellow Warlock
tell them that what we need to hear oh I
just got a stay at Seoul that's all I
got Stan you know I call it fail yeah
sighs we got a $2 tip of charm from
Eagles fan 76 once again I'm not a
sports fan I thought it was relevant but
don't forget how I'm going to fit this
talk okay good but be sure to get those
those those those Christ's in there for
the new welcome the new lord of the run
no doubt no doubt so look that's what I
got on that we move on we got a lot of
joy everybody got they bought off
everybody's doing that we can move on to
the Spidey joint yes
all right cool let's get to it so Spidey
is out I just give it a real good recap
you know Miles Morales looks like
insomniac games has announced that um it
is officially a standalone game so we
got that news officially shout - Jason
Schreyer he had the Bloomberg report out
there so they're saying that it
reportedly be smaller scope than the
original and compared it to something
like Uncharted Lost Legacy and then he
says part of the confusion comes from
comments from Simon rudder who is the
evey EVP of our European business at
Sony interactive entertainment so he was
the one that initially put the rhetoric
I should say rhetoric but the words out
that I saw which was like yo it's an
expansion and that um it's an
enhancement to the previous game he said
this is a substantial Miles Morales
component but it's an expansion element
and major enhancements of the game using
ps4 aspects with you know better pf5
technology and that's it so there was a
lot of confusion in the room a lot of
Twitter was lit people on my timeline
it's not the Jade L for setting the Sony
ghouls at me so damn J no dude they they
were anyway and we we thought you know
it was we thought it was it based on mr.
Rutter you know missus say let me let me
rant about that for momentarily
look I get it was I wrong technically I
was I wrong to make the statement
absolutely not right it is not my fault
people are like Oh at acute you need to
apologize you needed this you do that
how about you make that man's that lied
and didn't know what he was talking
about apologize don't make the dude that
was going off of what the dude that's
supposed to know what's what's going on
apologize let me not go let me let me
bring it back to you
my question is how is it that the VP
doesn't know that it's a stay at along
game I think the thing is something else
okay so you dig some up but let me get
enough of us the guest is here in place
when all the news went down when you
first saw miles did you know or feel it
was a standalone game where was you at
when when we first saw it on screen at
the show that's what that's what you see
and you have to take away from the fact
that we kept telling you as a standalone
but continue we officially give you the
the you got the you got the talk and
water bottle Maggie nodded we're not no
we're not going to that column century
I knew if it was spider-man it whether
you've seen it to like adding had said
you know I lost legacy honestly a lot of
people like that better like it looks
better
honestly lost legacies beautiful button
you know I didn't like the direction
they're going because this is uncharted
not girls gone wild is a copy a lot of
times I understand what he's saying I
got cash grab going into another
direction I feel good because if it was
spider-man to all you know it would have
been and if you've played the DLC you
know I understand that that story had to
be contain
somewhere thank you fax now my question
is should Xbox fans as a cordless let's
play fanboy for a minute should Xbox
fans hold that L because the so DV they
listen to the sodium VP that first said
it was an expansion look if somebody
comes home puts a statement especially
the dude at his level saying that he's
got to make sure he comes correct before
it says something because at people you
know how it is on Twitter told praising
but you know other than that other than
Xbox hold the LD oh I like the shot I
like the shot I like this at me
personally I was um I was gonna flame
him but no first this was two loops at I
just twittered a pic with 348 likes just
for addict he's talking about it has to
be over 300 G with the $2 super check
wasn't lost legacy and last light a
standalone DLC and you know what's
ironic about both of them they both have
febo you might be oh shout the vocals
Creed 47 more likes for addicts let's go
continue and we got carry our with the
$5 super jet I guess we're going to
ignore all the NBA 2k mat and just think
all the Dubin assassin creed and
fortnight kids that waiting on the PS 5
oh yeah it's exactly what slow-mo saying
they're not going to be able to get to P
as far because it will be sold out
instantly gonna be able to play the old
games on it so they're gonna have to buy
them again it would that be a barrier
for those individuals those children
would that be a attractive offer for
these kids that put hundreds and hours
in you know like fortnight is always
going to be available no matter what if
it's where it's it's a multi class you
know free to play offs
oh it's good oh thank you I think I gave
you one I just tell you the AL you right
now yeah yeah watch me dunk it right
back
hey plays I gave you the PlayStation Ali
baby go with it talk to you talk he set
you up you know he said you are always
on my playstation just because whatever
is around I was using it this time you
think that I'm weak do you have to jump
on the Xbox just put in your account at
all beat it won't work he doesn't you
know he goes to play and what pops up
and use my xbox I think sign up for Xbox
like you did that for you do you want to
know why that's like that you want to
know why remember what you said when you
couldn't talk inside your party chat at
the same time in playing games do you
want to know why you want to know who
showed you how to do it you want to know
how they got there
the hard books by the hard bucks and the
hard-earned money that was put there so
if you want to have a superior service
where your stuff is safe do you put your
credit card on your Playstation you
don't you don't do that right no exactly
mine is on my xbox and I can walk away
from it right but you can't do that
because you don't trust them let me tell
you why you don't trust no I don't trust
like you know why because you know if
your son gonna hold it at PlayStation he
just gonna buy a whole bunch of DC bucks
and you gonna be like oh my god what's
going on and you're not giving it back
they might block your account and tell
you you're done for but not to mention
they're sorry to interrupt you for a
second not to mention their blaze if you
if you if you feel like you're gonna get
cute and called the bank they gonna
block your whole gamertag exactly but
Microsoft will say okay we see what's
going on here this is not your normal
pattern here you go here's your money
back mm-hmm alright this is what happens
when you pay for a service when you get
into a club for free
anybody can get for this club but you
know he was coming into a safe
environment
sovereign knows all about me being in
the apartment life I'm how does that
work good like they have to like get
everyone's permission to move is a board
of directors that approves whether you
get are you part of that board so are
you part of that I'm not part of that I
managed to weasel my way in up against
the board and the board deemed him
worthy with the numbers a whole bunch of
zeros and threes and zeroes the finest
super check it seems like people are
confused on the difference between
stand-alone and dlc dlc requires the
original game to play stand-alone does
not require so he just says right he's
just clarifying what would it be but
what you don't understand is you being
bamboozled okay I've got all the DLC for
my spider-man and I love my spider-man
daily I'm going to get a PlayStation 5
I'm going to go get that Miles Morales
spider-man game um that's a storyline
that they started with the original
spider-man game so for you to say and
this is companies they not here for you
they're not you this is this is another
example of they're not your friendly not
your buddies and not you they're
homeboys they're not doing anything for
your benefit they're doing it for their
benefit is it a smart business
take your number one IP that you're
gonna have and put it over here against
a paywall if you want to play that game
if they're gonna do it this way you're
gonna have to pony up that $600 to get
the system and you're gonna have to buy
that game you're not gonna be able to
play that game on your existing hardware
is that a ball smooth yes it is will you
fall for it yes you will oh that's so
solve you were saying about the whole
day yeah I mean I'm the livestream the
first thing out of my mouth like okay
cool
what is this like what is it what is it
because I mean if you're looking at a
I'm more than happy to have this game
coming out at the launch of the system
at the same time you realize that's that
would make it about a year and a half
turn around so you know it's immediately
I'm like okay is this coming off a ps4
as well
or are you purposely gating it to the PS
5 and as a smaller title that's
obviously using the same tech just in
you know using whatever improvements the
PS 5 provides to kind of boost it up um
my thing is you don't be disingenuous
about what it is and if you're purposely
gating it to the PS 5 I think it's a bad
boom now let me let me fully say like
I'm copping this on because 5 I'm not
playing I'm not putting it on the ps4 if
it comes to be as war I'm cleaning on
peers let me actually solve do you think
there is a possibility then it comes to
ps4 I absolutely think it should if
because because now when you watched all
these videos again in 4k afterwards they
at the end of the video they would kind
of tell you where the game stood in
terms of PS 5 exclusive whatever there
were a few games now I almost say
there's a lot of a few games that at the
end set ps4 and PS 5 right now that goes
back to the whole you know we want to
make exclusive games of PS 5 we're not
doing this you know intergenerational
thing and that isn't the case so be
genuine they should have said that stuff
during the stream right right at the end
of the trailer just say what is coming
for and you know we don't generate
coming that it coming to multiple
platforms especially your prior platform
and the new platform right oh when it
comes to Miles Morales I think it should
come to both platforms I think it is it
is based on the old tech there's known
why this game can
run on a ps4 Pro if you get it to the
pro like whatever oh but I tell you this
like it just it goes back to what tell
me this right you're gonna be tight as a
PS 5 if somebody is somebody who loves
peers in the PlayStation brand you gotta
be tight if you can't get your hands on
a Playstation 5 at launch and you can't
play that game yeah and you implant imp
Leiby cuz they chose to gate it off
because that is a choice if you tell me
it was four years removed from the
launch of spider-man and this is an
ex-fighter man game I'm like cool they
this this is the absolutely the next
step this is the next one the tech is
built from the ground up for the
PlayStation 5 that is not the case with
this you know my girl looked and yeah
you ain't getting the PlayStation 5 yo
and you get and you get tight because
it's like really like so for me if this
is gated to the PS 5 it's a bad PR move
it just really is and I don't see any
reason for it and if it's not they
should have come out and said that
already because it coming out later that
that's the case let me ask you this what
cutoff as far as you know I believe it I
don't know who's Jim Ryan I think it was
Jim Ryan you know who said their goal is
to transition over people over to the
place as far as quickly as possible this
is out of their mouth so that the
strategy appears to be strong off yeah I
think they they want to get people in
and make them buy the console so you
know when I hear the executives saying
that does that not give you cause the
point that maybe they purposely will not
have this version because of it oh
absolutely it is absolutely a 100%
possibility on the Sony side that that
is the case um and that's that to me
that sad because you're looking at 130
million plus ps4 owners that you're
asking you're not even giving them the
soft transition you just
put them in the face whenever you just
left behind and like we've discussed in
the past I get it that is that is the
platform they stand on that's how they
differentiate their platform right but
let's keep it let's keep it a buck man
standing on that the exclusives are only
lost here that Square is getting old man
because if you look even at the at the
the third party stuff that's coming
exclusive to PlayStation it was a
Playstation I didn't hear people
flipping out that the games are open I'm
gonna PC right I didn't hear people
losing their minds because it's not
really an exclusive it's a console
exclusive you can choose to stand on
that Square and argue that point if you
want where but they're not a hundred
percent exclusive anymore so it's like
keeping that stuff close to the chest
business-wise just doesn't make sense
anymore the PlayStation brands this is
the thing I feel the PlayStation brand
those games are popular enough
well-known enough that you don't have to
worry about them they have to just be on
my platform in SA these these things
would thrive so much more if you just
let the reins loose and the thing is the
Sony's a hardware platform the hardware
no matter what is still gonna sell it's
still gonna sell fear and letting and
letting these games one transition back
and forth between your own platforms and
letting them be another plateau but what
about the argument of that that you know
there in the hallways selling business I
feel your points are you everything you
say legit I just say like you know
there's what there's two arguments here
right there's the argument that you have
the PlayStation 4 with this huge hundred
million or whatever it is base right
that you know if you put on that on both
platforms you're gonna eat substantially
right then there's the argument that yo
we're about to drop new hardware and we
want people in this new heart with this
new a curse it's a sell to get hardware
sales because they still seem to be you
know Microsoft's on the engagement in
the subscription thing but they seem to
still be using the hardware model as a
big basis for who they are as a brand so
right do you do you understand that
logic behind it or I don't
yeah I understand it but in that case
give me a
that's game because if you if you're
going by the lost legacy model legacy
model then Miles Morales is a ten-hour
game right
so you're let's say let's say the only
thing I care about at launch is Miles
Morales and that is the reason I buy a
Playstation 5 right you're it's a
ten-hour game that is not as it doesn't
have the same time hold on open world
that spider-man has it's just a fairly
straightforward way I think I was didn't
know I think I I don't hear anything
about the length of the game at all yeah
I'd be a shot that Jason shrunk because
he had put out I can't find it right now
it's gonna be the full city right so
right I'm sure yes okay spider-man miles
according to bloom this is a cell phone
with a significantly shorter runtime
then the original spider-man which the
original spider-man took about 40 hours
to complete and what they're gonna do
man is they're gonna have you collect
spiders on roofs instead of book bags
anyway so I mean to me the thing is the
fact that it's only two years removed
and even less than that because a lot of
steam was working on that DLC so even
less than that two years we move along
to the game you know it's built on that
tech you know it's not built from the
ground up for the PS 5 and that being
the case I think is it would it's it
would be crappy on their part not to
make a ps4 version that said I met my
fraud 100% I'm playing that on PS 5
that's straight up thank know though
you're gonna get these super chests you
know real quick you know I'll just see a
summit at Chad's got a address and
shout-out to the mods and everything
look we know everybody's staying on a
square with their console know that we
respect that the only thing we gotta say
y'all just no personal insults don't
first moto Marissa lies if you if you
want to disagree with someone just be
respectful that's all we ask
one shot personalize it the mods are
gonna come down hard on y'all and I'm
seeing a lot of that right now
and I'ma be real we don't want that
negativity here we not once you know
direct someone personally it goes left
so let's just keep it respectful and
y'all can agree to disagree and keep it
pushing that's all we gonna say this
game it's just you Joe Curt with the
final super check I think it is coming
to the ps4 because it says captured on
PS 5 why would they say that
unless it's coming on to something else
yeah that's true
ya mean sorry you finish what you're
saying ya done alright so first off I
want to say is we we finally debuted the
book of accident knees you can use those
emails right now second off I think it's
completely fraud miss what a Sony's
doing over there with that spider-man
like I get it
spider-man this is literally this this
is the best way to do it let's be real
here you it's not a full-blown game so
it probably didn't take nearly as much
money to develop this game than it would
for a full-blown sequel so they could
take a little bit of the hit for people
I don't go over to get just this game
right
spider-man's the perfect game to do it
with too because it's definitely you
know I hate bringing this up but I'll
also bet because of the sales of this
game so it very well so I can understand
why they would use spider-man as a
standalone and we can't really say that
this isn't something that Sony isn't
used to doing Sony does this pretty much
with every game they've done they did it
with you know I'm surprised we didn't
see horizon zero dawn set alone to be
honest with you but you know we saw it
with the what's that game that's what's
that games that came at the o with
infamous we saw infamous we saw it with
lack of us mm-hmm
and I'm wanting to say there's a third
game but they've done it with but you
know it's something that they they're
known to doing so I could completely
understand now whether or not it could
be on the ps4 and that's their decision
if they want to isolate that game from
the ps4 fans if you guys feel like that
is unacceptable vote with your wallet
tell them no we ain't buying this we a
about the slide oh damn well yeah well
did copy that bow around the game was
played Eliza V chair I feel like Miles
Morales is a PlayStation 5 tech showcase
and then solve you want to get to know
we got Smitty Smith for the father super
chat yeah boy got my own joint enjoy
Smitty Smith inspired book of acts we
got the Saudi baby yet
I did a solo gig is up man
you know you had a lot to say about this
joint where you at with this whole box
what I was saying I gotta tell you man
Mario's watching you guys he just came
down from those Mushroom Kingdom he does
not appreciate any this is unbelievable
but I think I'm in a dream I was so
happy to get on the show today like I
was up already I was dancing I'm like
right now alright so when I saw it all
right let me put my business hat on
right as an owner you want to put your
business in the best position for it to
win right and you must create that need
to have it doesn't matter if it's fake
need to have do can that Miles Morales
game be made on a Playstation 4 Pro yes
it can can it be made on a regular
PlayStation yes it can
games are scalable people let's let's
not act like they are not put on PC
first and their skill to the
specifications of each console so let's
let's just stop right there
there's no geometric engine that's in
there that is changing it for a
PlayStation 5 only that's not what's
going on here what's going on here is
they said what's something that we can
give them and a faster turnaround that
is desirable enough to force them to
have to purchase and that's a stroke of
genius right whereas Microsoft said okay
listen if you can't you know upgrade
this is ridiculous their life to their
life chatting the like so they are you
next you
next with that shirt overall how would
you like to get a 283 where the overalls
I need a big deal I want to know all all
those people that put those negatives in
there let's convert those into all right
so that's the stroke of genius as a
business and if you're leveraging the
fact that you can't do back compat in
that form you don't have to do it now
you don't have to worry about that when
you stated that this can only be done on
PlayStation 5 of the game that you see
it's only gonna be for PlayStation Prime
we're pushing the generation for it yes
if you make it that way if you make sure
that they can't play it on a Playstation
300 really they although I said three
podcasts at all no I said that I said
that three podcasts ago good continue
last ones not fair because it was like
that for the 7000 won that definitely
got over three listen guys it's you may
not like it right and it may seem like
it's unfair right and it may seem super
unfair when you're not able to get a
PlayStation 5 this year right and you
gotta wait in the other scrounge and you
gotta find your way to get one just to
play the Miles Morales game and I think
that's super unfair to the people that
support a Playstation and supported that
game and supported all the DLC and one
can
in you that story and their story
properly but again this is business and
they're not your friends and not your
buddies if you don't believe in this
business practice if you don't like this
business practice except vote what you
dollar
but sometimes standing on that square is
very hurtful and that game is something
that you want to play I truly want to
play it what I be really pissed off if I
didn't have the money to get it and I
won't be able to play it on my existing
hardware that I do have the one thing
that both of these consoles have made it
easy for me to do is to sell this old
hardware so I can have the money to get
the new hardware Microsoft made it a
little bit more easier in the sense that
I guess I like new tech if I didn't have
to upgrade then I wouldn't I can
actually play it but there's some games
that can only be played on X Sony made
it my decision completely flawless that
PlayStation 4 is dead it's done and he
told you right there on Thursday this is
how we kill a fan-based as has a 30 135
million strong supporters that supported
us and got us here this is how we dead
y'all off and show you we don't care
about what you want or what you only
everything sounds so good I don't
believe none of the nonce it's coming on
but it sounds so good like he's praising
him a person he showed you he doesn't
care about you at all and going forward
if you don't have a PlayStation 5 no
Miles Morales for you for her says King
is Friday
yeah I'm fraud him but if don't got
their PlayStation 5 you got no no
spider-man for you so how am i fraud in
if I'm telling you what you don't want
to see he told you it's only gonna be on
a Playstation 5 and if you don't like it
that's on you but I'm telling you I'll
be playing with the Miles Morales with
this internal system oh you don't like
you don't like that number either well
when that number comes out in this 599
now son you're never
again 599 dollars and if you're not and
you just don't win I'll be there
yo we missed the super chest right so I
got cash no check get these like stuff
to get addict and one of them was 290
Dom but I'll go ahead and give it to you
guys so I'll do the trucker thing his
word Lord of his word
well we have made way a monster with the
file so but yet I feel Sony doesn't have
the infrastructure to handle to Jen's
Plus Microsoft should buy WB games and
make Batman exclusive fight fire with
fire
so we got a $5 super track from JD gamer
did anyone catch that shade Sony was
thrown by bringing back aid from odd
world as a launch title for the psy
basically saying we take your we talking
you taking we taking your stuff Xbox
mmm-hmm odd word used to be on Xbox I
mean it exclusive odd world a little
strange wrath originally so we got a
$2.00 super chair from the Raven flow PS
is over 110 million it's going to sell
130 I guess by the end of the generation
I don't know Ltd stand 40 yeah
interesting but I can't get his boss you
know it's just an interesting approach
you know it's we got to see how this
thing works out for them I mean I'm
saying at the end of the day look I'm
competent regardless those heavy labor
gall is you know Witter you copy if it's
at launch I because that's one of the
few things that really interested me
before what happens but you don't like
backing off but anyway it's a great
I need that Demon Souls we got we just
got to see man hardest thing works out
for them at the end of the day it's a
very bullish approach unless they get
down what we call it kid get down a
later get down and later and that's
literally what Jim Ryan is saying and if
you wanna you know I'm saying it is what
it is but I'm tell you this regardless
to what I'm there like I know people's
coming at me I'm there it was they like
make no mistake so we say I'll go the
question is going to be like King said
like will I doubt it but will this
PlayStation 4
that's on the fence revolt like I can't
see them say you're not going to like we
see them say wow these people a lot of
these people probably won't even know
it's on the ps5 only right and then when
they do find out they will come on by
that series acts like they should have
been doing Tory but that's what I got
I'm gonna move on man so next joint I
believe so like I said it off - I don't
know if you would pay attention this is
gonna be quick so yes so Nintendo yeah
apparently uh going back it is Michael
Vick so backing on back in April Oh
South Pole towel season four he had a
random pups an article about saying that
Nintendo had come out and said that
there were some Nintendo accounts that
had been hacked know what you're doing
let's kiss a switch coming Inhofe's by
those members man let's get this going
so the original number of hacked
accounts was reportedly a hundred and
sixty thousand the actual number is
actually close to the double wide
disrespectfully stop putting switch code
at high continue now keep it up you guys
keep it up don't listen to Lord country
basically three hundred thousand
Nintendo accounts have been compromised
basically now the thing is according to
Nintendo only about 1% of those were
used to make actual fraudulent purchases
and the owners of set accounts that have
managed to get it may change it
passwords whatever so it said it was
clear to say listen like we weren't
hacked like they managed to get this
through some third party but it wasn't
us that was act so either way 300,000
intend to accounts got hacked
all I have to
is two-factor authentication yes look
it's not company hot right now so bad
it's a sad day for the game you know low
two-factor authentication man it's
certain platforms that I'm just not
giving about credit card I just don't
understand why you don't have that like
yeah like I don't understand why you
don't have that at the start because you
know you're still implying that but
you've had they tell us have plenty of
time to put this feature in the in their
in their ecosystem keep the saying
snitch I'm capable to save energy nice
it's a terrible look it's so awful at
the end of the day it's no excuse you
already got some issues with the
infrastructure how bare-bones it is you
know I'm saying you already got it
listen they should be kognito spending
money they should be raked over the
coals for I'm not gonna let them slide
with that they got the nerve to be
getting hacked online and they really
got no infrastructure to be talking
nobody in doing that online so that
that's the part that got me bad and then
like I say for word of advice if there's
any company Nintendo and maybe Sony I
don't know how do you feel uncomfortable
with with their network two-factor
authentication and PayPal PayPal so that
you do not give people a direct route to
stealing your information and it's a bad
luck cuz was it what was it solved 160
at first and now city forest
yeah 160 at first and then when they
really looked dug deep it was three
hundred thousand yes you know we bend
the knee not coming at Mario's is let me
know I had to get added security
you have to watch over my switch at
night because we don't know where they
come from like Nintendo the the way
Nintendo just wiggled it way out of that
they was like yo that wasn't us blames
of us yes so the fact that you lost what
was that yeah three grand you lost three
grand on VC bucks maybe next time you
might change some up Nintendo
at no point our will lady holding that
one that's all you you just now if this
goes into what I tell y'all before
mm-hmm when you feel comfortable with a
company you put your credit card and you
walk away you good you good money you
understand that they got your back
you know like Allstate you know it's
nice and surance policy Sony has this
problem a lot and now we're seeing that
from Nintendo as backdoors into
something that they don't really have
going on to allow people to get into the
old situations so they're not taking any
accountability to this at all and as a
third party person whatever they got it
through the dark web I'm sorry for you
listen it's about time we saw holding
these companies accountable that's a
they should not be able to get off the
hook if you purchase their their their
product and your information is on their
product and you say that you were
supposed to be secure you feel secure in
purchasing it they had no problem with
taking your money but when you have a
problem they turn their back to you make
this a warning
hold them accountable for it oh do
whatever you got to do to get back what
you lost
also you have that same level of energy
for the companies that give you back yes
we got we got something breaking news
shout-out to slow-mo backslap moderator
of the chat you just what's in about 10
there is some Twitter beef going on
between Neil druckmann
and Jason Schreyer so I guess Jason sure
I have made a comment about um you know
she tries the wrong person you want me
guess about you know jokes about far as
the industry and stuff like that
chuckle buds firing back with all due
respect I find these kind of jokes to be
unproductive at best and I'm trying to
get to the heart okay here it also ain't
that corny borrowed tell me how luca
already posted watching people in the
industry be as pettiest people in our
communities hilarious hey jason shaw hey
Neil this is wildly personal still not
sure why you feel the need to go after
him go at me multiple times for
expressing that I felt the analogy was
tacky
I sure hope is not related to my release
it reporting on your studio be well and
best of luck okay so now we another back
or Corey Berra log has just jumped in it
as well and he said twit tweets are
difficult to interpret nuanced but I
have yet I have to say that lately you
have come across a bit bully Jason right
I get that your bread and butter is
tearing us down but not everything is
about your book or articles sometimes
it's just about being decent to each
other
Jason Schreyer with the clap back Wow
Corey bar log if by us you mean people
in power who facilitate the overwork and
exploitation of Labor then sure I'd be
proud to say my bread and butter is
tearing you down
it's my us you mean game de villiers Dan
that's nonsense and we both know it
there is some beef going on South can
you give us context what there was a
review of The Last of Us - um I forgot
the site now I know it wasn't no it was
a dude it was a dude it was different it
was a different channel and dude
actually he knows he knows Jason right
so in his review he said that the Last
of Us - made him feel the same way as
when he watched Schindler's List right
he was talking about the feelings that
it evoked in him
right so Jason came at him and said I
think you know I
respect but I think you know comparing a
game a video game about the
post-apocalypse to the actual Holocaust
that actually happened
I think it's tacky and I think that's a
little too much I do about it is what he
said he didn't the guy was simply saying
what being in the theater watching that
movie how it made him feel and he didn't
specifically say anything about who we
apart from that it made him feel these
very powerful feelings so I picked
another movie to decide to make the same
point yes but he didn't he wasn't
speaking of putting them on equal levels
he said it made him they've made him
feel like very strong feelings he Jason
got on him for that attacked it pletely
and it was a back and forth he was like
dude you know me like why would you have
to why would you come after Jason's
entire persona is fighting for
developers I got you but what does that
have to do with attacking a guy
reviewing so the thing is he dude got at
Jason and said look man you know me if
you felt this way why did you have to
make a big statement of it on Twitter
just DM me we'll talk about it and then
you know but Jason immediately he just
came out on Twitter and it became a
thing on Twitter so you know honestly
what Neil is saying about you know the
way he attacks people like I get the
dudes III you know I don't I don't see
the issue what to do comparing it to
Schindler's this in that regard like if
he could be compared content to content
yeah would have a problem with that
right because they're absolutely not
speaking about the same thing but
certain things evoke feelings in you and
if you think that comparison yes could
he have made a different president yes
but he made that comparison just on how
it made me feel I think that's his right
to do that I don't think he was out of
line to do that but but I can't disagree
with Jason's perspective as they look
like Schindler's List was based off like
crazy
infants happening in the world yeah
correct yeah that's exactly what it was
correct but he was I do think about
magnitude of it for him how he thought I
just took to me personally I just don't
see anything in in the last of us making
you think of the horrible Vince that
went over there why ever
we haven't played you can't say that we
can't we can't say that again and
everybody takes things differently and I
mean looking at the way you play games
now you're gonna run through the game
like you it's just one of those things
like I know I'm gonna sit there and I'm
gonna analyze every little bit of glass
no starches right like I'm gonna do that
so I'm gonna have strong feelings on it
either way
you know what I mean um so I just to me
unless the direct comparison was made to
like scenes in Schindler's List like
that I would have a problem with in
terms of what it evokes in you it's just
saying that and like it was an all it
was he made that stick and moved on
what's the game with Jeff kanata and
this was what I mean that's him it's
here gotcha gotcha
so so here's the thing but the thing to
me that is even more interesting is Cory
bar log in this you know saying yeah I
like and I like Cory and I feel like
what Cory said is it false
Cory was just he is seen on his Twitter
and we can't like Jason don't like the
smoke Jason Pro developer as far as
defending as far as the righteous stuff
but he kind of attacked him in saying
like he's almost like you're not and
that he's like we say you I get the
church off I would understand Jason
being upset over that because almost
everything he writes is Pro developer
like almost you you made it seem like
the only reason why he's bringing this
stuff up is because of his book and mr.
Carson one when you when you do that you
attacking his credibility you attacking
his integrity and you attacking a
platform that he's been fighting for for
so long
like you know you discrediting him and I
can understand him being completely
upset with it so who are you talking
about I'm talking about Jason's right if
you if you're gonna say that uh the only
reason why he's putting the stuff out
because of his book or whatever I don't
think that's it Jewish like Jason is
Jewish he was like all right so that's
my answer my family
- Tiffany their peaceful body how they
supposed to interpret how they offended
yes they're like when you when you make
statements like this reminds me of
Schindler's List and if he is completely
sensitive to that
you know you will probably say something
like you know you could use something
else other than that you know this is a
fictional game and made in a fictional
world that didn't ever happen and you're
talking about stuff that did happen to
people that you know that this affects
so you have to have a sensitivity when
you say certain things you just can't
just be spewing out stuff and not
thinking repercussions is going to come
your way especially right about now so I
understand you know what I really have a
lot of empathy for him because a lot of
stuff that he does is completely
selfless and he hangs out on this branch
fighting and you know and it's not like
some of the times he's not completely
100 percent right right so that that
kind of bad you know what it just felt
like it just felt like he he immediately
assumed the intent was there rather than
finding out first and then having a
dialogue about it what get a problem is
it let's be real this is what happens
what exactly what go public let these do
she's beautiful you know say like
there's just all this Twitter beef in
personal attacks and all in a state they
just got it shows we got respect we met
Corey obviously got Jason on the show
there's an so it's like I just think
they both need to just calm down
he's gonna calm down give it a full of
Twitter and hash it out like men I
understand my sensitivity good at it I
think that Jason Schwarz not in the
wrong for be like I didn't even know he
was Jewish in like knowing he was Jewish
like yeah people need a lay off like
that like and yeah if you're right like
you're I'm not Jewish I wasn't raised in
a Jewish family I'm sure you that is
talked about all the time right so like
you know it's definitely gonna hit it
hit a nerve in and I do think that Loki
poisoned the wrong for like implying
that he ain't about the developers it's
like yeah I was that was a tough one
that was a tough one I mean dudes are
taking sides and oh
we'll say is this you know Jason we love
him there is a sensitivity he can't his
blonde was crazy if he disagreed
disagree with him but I can't to King's
point he's a person that always puts
himself on the limb to fight for
developer rice but necessarily he don't
really have to do he could protect
himself he could just cash his check in
as far as getting you know his articles
office stuff like that he always seemed
he seems to be wanting to push the
industry in a pro-union for developers
and the whole thing so look me I hope
them brothers work it out cuz Corey is a
good I really quarries one of the like
he's literally one of those people in
the industry that I'm like he's got no
blood no no he had no bad blood like to
see him in me it really bothers me but
you'll shout the slow-mo hybrid
attention yes I guess that became the
final but I I agree with everything you
guys say except for the fact that it
felt like he just jumped the gun and and
he do in the way he attacked them
because they will do it aggressively it
was a recipe like just pointing out no
it was aggressive because anything is
he's like what did neo drunk might have
to do with it
I don't specifically know how that that
interaction happened I just know the
Kannada thing and how that came about
and I'm sure that's you know I don't
know how he'll responded to that just
hold on slow mo follows why couldn't
Jason provide Jeff the same courtesy of
a private convo instead of public shots
that he wanted from it and there you go
yeah and after what it is like he
attacked them and then it became a thing
on when it could have been something
that couldn't they could have discussed
yes and then any of anything you know
you know Jeff come out and make a
statement about it whatever the case
from you'll find where the conversation
started look at his review the the
comparison boy gonna be back in the gym
wait all for me crazy this very good
legs back in a bill that we use do this
poll we gotta get up out of here man
what a crazy crazy show so if I can find
the do I'll people with the recent
announcement of the PlayStation 5
digital edition console how do you think
Sony should position its configuration
in preparation for the Xbox Lockhart the
choices are a same price as PS 5 but
with a larger SSD for more digital games
be $100 cheaper than a PS 5 take the
hallway loss to undercut Lockhart or C I
don't care cuz I'm still confused by two
skills at lunch
Lord blazed forth
okay so dear Episode II baby was going
on wicked the fire people find you glad
to have you in a room brother long
overdue I told you what's going to
happen
I told you believe what I told was going
to happen we're gonna find people find
you yeah follow me at blaze 4k YouTube
okay Twitter and if y'all if you play
some game I play with all time but King
he hasn't get on discord I'm doing
discord today we will I could say that
um but yeah you just add me you know you
know I'm def all that smoke I don't care
about know that stuff but I found out
that I have to pay to play online when
it comes to PlayStation and they're not
getting my money no every time I went
over there to play somebody you know
fighting game let's go do this I totally
forget that I gotta give them some bucks
and I'm never giving them a dollar
because I'm only over there to play
single-player games they have no online
component to it so why should I have
anything to do with online with them
right talk to you on end
thank you thank you ladies got a widow
TW places are our PSN name is Xbox 360
Xbox my PSN name is xbox 360 lover oh
one yes someone get cake no I'm dead
center dancers you don't have he refuses
to change now for free first time
oh I'm not changing that at all think
about it this way right I put Xbox 360
lover at first and it was like no that
means somebody out there has Xbox and I
gotta have a one that's my god yo blaze
man with our GT solid cast was going on
with that Friday
are you team in a solid you know Muslim
man good to have you know rum always
gotta get that Sony representation a
they get mad a like I don't have enough
Sony got my I got you we got we got
stuff coming man no Boston you you
definitely we won't get to that pay
taxes Fat Boy next year when things
going things get right definitely got
linked up probably they're joke with the
Lord's you already know Lord addict
trucker addict is official in the row
the likes have been reached and overalls
the OshKosh B'gosh is on deck
first off you can find me at Walmart
unfortunately buying a pair of overalls
but we will talk about that this is how
this is all work I don't know did you
ever order those trucker the trucker hat
solve or do we don't need to do that it
is it is in rowdy I want to look dirty
with a nipple hole
you know I will be where I will be
wearing an IOT shirt that's not happy
I'm not going there with the best for
them remember once I get that I'll go
get the overalls you know and then that
and then the week after that is when
I'll wear the overalls
the trucker hat like you know the only
reason I'm doing this cuz you know the
community's been so good to us and you
guys deserve that entertainment first
off I want to say you know if you guys
notice the The Book of X and the knees
in here you know first off look we've
got to give a huge shout out to there's
definitely good he's doing all kits and
overalls you know I'm going to work so
that's when you can find me humble shout
out to blaze I got a special place in my
heart for Boston man I love Boston went
to school of Boston and the New Orleans
New England area so I can't wait to get
up with you next week next year a pax oh
thank you guys in the chat like you know
guys this has gone down as a historic
episode of IOP and it's all thanks to
you guys like you guys the support the
love you guys are in there all week long
you guys are just waiting for the show
it is this it's amazing to know where we
came from to see where we are is kind of
bananas man so thank you guys much
appreciate it
the barest of chests will be ready we
cannot wait to see that IOP logo
emblazoned on the pectorals justjust you
think of it this way King when you go to
eat through your shirt yeah you free
promotion for us bro no you just go to
the beach and you live our views go up
shout out the will be hood for putting
the pressure in the gate to reach the
unachievable we did it solve did it as a
joke but this was a joke
no worst one for that one to tear like
it was there was a couple of them and we
was like look we got to be realistic
let's take them all but we kept that one
because it was a joke when we figures we
get the pocky challenge immediately like
we said in the fourth king to do this
and the other one was just literally a
throwaway tear just to be put in there
for no reason I'll push out the ruby
hood gave him via the Box all those
dudes done son here I feel real good no
that's dead as the New York so uh New
Cairo what's up go hit that go see that
go understand why you forgot we'll make
it spin oh no it was spinning you
looking at me weird you come around
Mario is security really do giving me a
little bit bad bye let me turn off my
light man switch coming in hi turn off
my camera - you scared
remember that Mario that was peeking
behind the curtains yeah put them all
the way down the hole with his little
head sticking out I was gonna do some
creepy stuff I was like ma'am if
anyone's good it means you there's a
there's a there's a picture of Mario
with like this curtain use that and meme
us like crazy I want to see what people
come up with if anyone's gonna be there
yes well you could catch me on weapon
will tonight um I definitely have to get
over there you know I just said you know
what I work at night and to do to
podcast is really is really something
cause trust me guys this from doing this
podcast it may not seem like something
but you try sitting down in a chair
before I go to the bathroom and all this
other stuff but I'm like new Kos is up
go over there check that out also go to
the last word with local you know any
bounces yo I had somebody in my chat
talk about cactus right and it was like
yeah you know yeah you know what Jackie
said Williams on IOP you're lying
I don't know he was on before we started
getting need a repeat yes we definitely
need to come back on not gonna have a
big head of nothing for a little podcast
we have some of the most heavy hitting
dudes in the world on on this show and
in his genuine love I said yo and I said
I'm not telling you to go listen to the
last word for no reason I said yeah
listen because they were asking me about
light and all this other stuff I said
clearly you don't know what the hell is
going on so what I want you to do is
just go watch the last words and go see
what's going on and then come back to me
because I don't have time to be taking
you through college courses and giving
you cliff notes of what's going on I'm
not your buddy like that so get it done
and come back because if I gotta go to
school every week on Fridays you got to
go to school same time bro all right you
know it's supporting this but um will me
hood
I'm still my this is a dream that I
can't believe it's the dream in a good
way it's like you ever been in a dream
and you're going down the steps but you
keep going down the steps and there's no
way for you to get out the building down
you going down
you have put me in a perpetual loop and
I'm sitting there like this didn't
really just happen yeah buddy
he said love you easy two cherries I
love oh you must have pay today what
they will be doing oh my god oh my god
really really strong anyway guys have a
nice week we got a five Canadian super
chat from squirrely yes hey thanks for
willing me for bread and let it be a
lesson for throwing shade that shout out
the squirrely jam for aggressively
making this happen as well he put the
pressure on so squirrely definitely a
shout to yelled over all that polar
bears to your house yes loius low we hit
the thousand dollar face you hit begs
there will be hood as a result now we're
not talking like he completed the
thousand he dropped a thousands Robbie
yeah so as a result we will watch it in
basement as Salzburg said Lord life yeah
well in a tattoo parlor mm-hmm the
camera on live
mhm well me hoods enjoyment yes we
members only happens first will be its
first yeah well because then afterwards
we'll give it to the members and then
later on that night it'll be for members
and HP on members only yes oh if anybody
is watching right now and you think
you're gonna see nipple for free just
for youthful we shout out the holy faith
King you are going to respect wills
meanie patronage you know spoke at no
point in time will nipple be in your eye
socket
wait bro
yes got a pay-to-play big shower episode
Issei inside gaming drops of mine let's
cry yeah saluted here silently yeah we
can get a lot of love men and then and
then probably within the next three
weeks I'll be doing the Attic trucker
one a character video this is crazy look
yo I don't even know what to say about
today today was absolutely insane first
of all salute ablaze by bro for coming
through that's my god me off my team I
didn't even give respect to the guest
game to blaze that was winner on
Thursday and it is his reaction with us
that means a lot brother and I
appreciate you and I appreciate you
coming on Sunday right after and
definitely engaging in our little fun
bounces back and you definitely show
that you're a good representation for
PlayStation nation and a wreck you
brother absolutely and he always calls
it fair man salute them I know you have
to dip out real quick so families aren't
going on but salute to him again suits
you to chat like yeah I have no idea man
like from where we came from solve and
the seated and add a curtain attic know
like king no you know I'm saying like to
see what this is going and I already
know it's I'm humbled to do this we I'm
humble too that's not the language we
got a draw that appears which we could
properly remove it so it always be a
staple of I open one all the members
have achieved the people that's we we
can have other thousand dollar tears
pertaining the king
look your job I got a $2.00 superfan
respect to our respective lords and
their hard work we've got a preciate
every three hours kids got it go look we
got to leave y'all with the promo joint
for again for those in the realm anata
where you know i'm saying we still got a
promotion for that series ex and all
that good stuff
hello everybody enjoy your Sunday wow
you guys are something else man we see
you guys next week there is xox hi I'm
looking I guess and we're bringing to
you an exciting new giveaway this
giveaway is like none other
we'll be giving away an Xbox Series X
that's right you heard me right the
brand new console launching from
Microsoft this year well this is how
you're able to be part of that giveaway
there's two ways to get your name thrown
in the head for the raffle one become a
member of the realm
that's that joy button hit hit that joy
button you hit their joint button down
at the bottom and you can become a
member and also another way is by
becoming a patreon member so you can be
part of the realm as well now this is
brought to you by cat daddy fat stacks a
member and lord of the realm a very
generous person that's in our community
and this community is beautiful so
remember you can have one entry by
hitting that join button and becoming a
member of the realm and also you can
have another entry by being a patreon
now you said King what if I'm a member
of both while your name gets thrown in
the Hat two times so please like follow
subscribe join or become a patreon
member or become both and your name is
in the Hat to get that Xbox Series X as
to who did their for you
sweepstakes this is wonderful this is
something that I'm sure that you will
enjoy